people
okay everybody uh representative Brown
representative y Kell please take your
here morning everybody Welcome uh we
will start today with the pledge and uh
today representative uh stavis you are
pledge
thank you representative
rooll thank you Mr chairman uh
Vice chairman in power here clerk is
here representative
Guffy representative lales here
representative Ella
present representative
Kelly representative aood president
representative
Brown
here representative
kahill here representative stavis here
representative
Tetro represent CH 11 representative
Gilman here representative major here
representative
Gallagher here okay thank you uh
representative Hicks I'm here
representative Howland here
representative free
here representative frch I'm here and
chair chairman turot
present thank you Mr Clark okay uh
before we get going just too quick quick
items for the committee uh one uh next
week will be on Wednesday I know we've
already talked about that in the morning
we are going to be executing uh a long
list of bills you may have already
gotten that notice there might be some
slight changes but uh we'll be executing
in the morning and then uh taking a
couple of public hearings I think four
or so in that on the uh in the afternoon
on
Wednesday uh um the other thing I'd like
to comment on is I'm impressed at the
attendance of this committee I
gave comment uh introduced a bill last
one of my two bills last week in in
another committee and it was about a
third of the committee present and I'm
just I know almost every time our
committee has close to 100% attendance
so I'm just just want to say I'm
impressed by that after seeing what
other committees do uh with that we are
going to open up our hearings today with
House Bill
1105 relative to the application of a
local tax
cap and with
that uh oh also if anybody in the
back intends to speak make sure you have
your PIN card signed and brought to the
front which I see they have been done so
uh with 11:05 Prime Prime sponsor
representative power the floor is yours
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
committee members as the prime sponsor I
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today House Bill 1105 for the
record I am representative Diane power I
represent the towns of Brookline Mason
in Greenville in Hillsboro County
District
36 to begin this bill was filed upon the
request of a number of my constituents
this is a simple straightforward Bill
the purpose of this bill is to clarify
the statute pertaining to the local tax
cap the problem that this bill seeks to
solve or address is that the current
statutory language is unclear resulting
in the RSA being incorrectly interpreted
and improperly applied by towns and
districts that have adopted this local
tax cap this ambiguity undoubtedly can
lead to a patchwork of application
across the granite state more
specifically at least one town and one
school district erroneously interprets
the term the budget to mean the
operating budget only this
interpretation is both Incorrect and
illogical which is why this bill is
needed now first it's important to
understand the term the
budget so RSA 32 colon
5-b Roman numeral 1 local tax cap refers
to the term the
budget it reads the estimated amount of
local taxes to be raised for this fiscal
year as shown on the budget certified by
the governing body or the budget
committee and posted with the warrant
for the annual meeting pursuant to RSA
32 2 colon 5 additionally under
Section Roman numeral 2 it references
quote the amount of local taxes raised
by the town or District as reported to
the Department of Revenue
Administration commonly known as
Dr so the local tax cap RSA cites two
important elements the budget reported
so next it's important to understand
what the budget reported to the Dr what
does that mean so as a former chair of
the Hollis Brook line Cooperative School
District budget committee I know that
the budget is reported to the Dr using
the appropriate form so towns use the
ms26 and the MS 737 forms and school
districts use the ms26 six and ms27
forms so in each of these Ms forms
there's a budget summary
page so on the handout if you look at
page
two where at the top of the page it's
2022 ms26 for the Brookline School
2023 on this on this form and all the
other Ms forms that I mentioned the
budget summary clearly shows two
important items first is the total
Appropriations this is the amount the
estimated amount of local taxes to be
raised for the fiscal year and it's
comprised of not just one item but of
three components with a dollar figure
and as you can see on this this form
here it can consists of the operating
budget
Appropriations special warrant articles
and individual warrant articles to be
clear all warrant articles with
Appropriations are included in the
budget second the estimated revenues and
credits in the State education tax SLG
grant that is then subtracted from the
total Appropriations to compute the
estimate
amount of taxes to be raised this figure
is then used in the calculation for the
local tax cap
compliance therefore to be very clear
the estimated amount of local taxes to
be raised is not just the operating
budget and it's not just based on the
operating budget to reiterate it
includes the operating budget as well as
warrant articles
next I think it's important because
while this bill is very simple and
straightforward it's in my opinion
people do not understand the statute so
I just want to give you an example of
how the language under the local tax cap
is misinterpreted and
misapplied so looking at page three of
the
handout um this is some information with
regards to the Brookline School district
for fiscal year 23 so since the adoption
of the tax
cap in the Brookline School District the
residents the voters voted to adopt an
8% tax cap so in this Brookline School
District through fiscal year 2023 the
Brookline School Board properly computed
compliance with this 8% tax cap as shown
uh on in the top
slide
so the school board listed the
appropriate operating budget and the
warrant articles as you can see and then
that was added together to come to the
figure of the total warrant which that's
your total
Appropriations then they properly
subtracted as you can see local revenue
and state aid grant and the retained
state tax to come up to the figure which
is the total tax effort that you see in
the bottom line so again the total tax
effort is the estimated amount of local
taxes to be raised for the given fiscal
year so then the bottom two slides on
the same page
three um gives an overview of the
warrant and it shows all warrant
articles with
Appropriations so the tax effort
calculation was done in fiscal year 2022
and
2023 for comparison to ensure that the
8% tax cap was abided by and that the
proposed fiscal year 2023 tax effort
didn't exceed um that the previous
year's tax effort so now if we look on
page
four you can see that now suddenly the
Brookline School District changed its
methodology in calculating the tax
effort in my opinion likely because they
wanted to propose higher spending so as
you can see with this new methodology
only the operating budget was considered
and that was used as a total
Appropriations and this is incorrect
this is an
incorrect application of the local tax
cap statute so in the top slide um you
can see that there are no warrant
articles listed nor is there a warrant
line listed in this computation and so
therefore when you do all the
calculations the Brookline School
District or School Board said that the
tax effort was being reported as
7.6% however in the bottom slide you can
clearly see that with the overview of
the warrant there are in fact four
warrant articles with Appropriations
$867,000 that are wrong ignored in this
tax
computation however if you apply the
correct me methodology that they had
previously been using and do the
calculations and you include the bud the
operating budget and all the other
warrant articles with Appropriations the
estimated amount of local taxes to be
raised in that calculation the proposed
tax effort was actually 12
.7% thereby exceeding the tax cap of
8% okay so this brings us to the
solution to the obvious problem this
bill makes clear that all warrant
articles that raise an appropriate
taxpayer dollars shall be subject to the
local tax cap this means that all
articles placed on the warrant that
raise funds through taxation shall be
included in the tax effort
calculation which is used to determine
if this proposed it's the proposed
spending is it compliant with the local
tax cap that's been adopted it's also
important to note that this bill in no
way affects the ability of the town or
District to raise and appropriate funds
the purpose of a local tax cap is to
limit proposed
Appropriations by the governing body at
the annual meeting to be clear the bill
does not affect the ability of the
voters to override the tax cap and this
bill does not limit the voter's
authority to either increase or decrease
the amount of any
appropriation or the total amount of all
Appropriations in summary by clarifying
that all recommended Appropriations in
the warrant be included in the tax
effort calculation for the local tax cap
this bill upholds the legislative intent
of the local tax cap statute and also by
eliminating ambiguous statutory language
this bill provides much needed Clarity
which by the way aligns with an
important New Hampshire Municipal
Association policy to quote encourage
Clarity and the elimination of ambiguity
and statutory language thank you Mr
chairman and with that I end my
testimony or Bill intruction thank you
thank you representative are there
questions from the
committee repesentative Holland okay
you're gonna have to I apologize for my
extreme ignorance on tax caps because
I've never worked under
one but I think at the end you kind of
answered my question so in other words
uh I or the the governing body comes
forward they go to the to the public
hearing on the budget and they list down
let's say we have and you had here like
say number three is your operating
budget and you have you add like say
four other warrants that are on there
the governing body isn't limited if they
say look if you approve all these it's
going to be 10% they're still allowed to
do that right and then the voters can at
that point when it goes on to the ballot
and they vote on it they can say you
know what I'm going to pick all four of
those warrants and it's going to be 10%
and we're going to override the tax cap
or I'm only going to do say three out of
four of those and it meets the tax cap
that still holds right thank you
representative that's that's an an
interesting um point and you would be
correct to be very clear this is not a
spending cap this is a tax effort cap
and moreover
as the local tax caps statutory section
is is
written it simply limits what the
elected body which is the governing body
in these cases can bring forward can put
on the table can propose to the
legislative body which is the the voters
that's just the starting point that's
all this does like I said it
doesn't impede limit the ability of the
voters at the annual meeting to change
that so it's it's it focuses on what can
be brought forward does that answer the
question I can I follow up is that is
that okay you may go ahead um so kind of
so in other words you're saying that the
legislative body if the tax cap is 8% I
can't bring Warren uh for forward as a
as a governing body that exceed the 8%
right that that would be correct yeah
correct representative
lales thank you and and thank you for
taking my question so in representative
howland's case where they had four
warrant articles in addition to the
operating budget and if they added up
all those warrant articles they would
exceed the tax cap they couldn't do that
correct correct because the then
therefore they'd be bringing something
forward that exceeds the tax
count follow up Mr chairman follow up so
how would the body
propose something to override the tax
cap could you restate the question let's
say in in this in representative
howland's case MH he had four warant
articles three of them got under the tax
cap but the fourth would exceed the tax
cap how could the legislative body pass
that fourth warrant article to override
the tax cap how could the legislative
body pass
it that they they they they they they
would
vote as they would vote on on any
warrant article but I think the key is
is the the
article okay thank you representative
priest thank you uh Mr chairman uh and
thank you for taking my question you
mentioned Brookline uh several times in
your testimony and the warrants that
they brought forth could you describe
what the warrants were
and why they were so detrimental to the
budget thank thank you representative
for your question
I with regard to Brook line it just so
happens that that's one of my um towns
that I represent so therefore I am very
familiar um with this the the local tax
cap because Brookline School District
has one and that was just an
example so I
with all due respect I don't feel that
your question is Germaine to the bill
this is simply just an
example
[Music]
and representative power I I I would
tend to agree I
think the what the uh
presenter is showing is dollar amounts
not specifically
what the appropriation
uh for the warrants are so I would agree
with her it's a little non-gain but if
you'd like a followup representative PRI
I would and and the reasoning for my
question is these warrants would not be
brought up is that correct if there
wasn't a problem or an issue they wanted
to deal with thank you for the question
representative so so of course a
responsible um governing
body they would put forth you know Artic
warrant articles to raise an appropriate
taxes however what we need to keep in
mind is that for those towns in
districts that have adopted a local tax
cap the people the voters in the town or
the district they have made it clear
through their you know passage of the
local tax cap which is a 60% super
majority to pass it they are
it's enabling legisl enabling statute
they are saying to the governing body
that you need to make choices you need
to put forward a a a you know spending
proposals that are within the tax cap so
with with it at any thank you for taking
my question represent power so
based on the questioning that I've
heard my thought goes to we're trying to
limit I'm going to get to a question
here we're trying to limit the spending
so that it doesn't go over the 8%
because of the super majority says we
don't want to spend that but let's say
there's some type of emergency
situation and they want to spend
something would they have to vote
basically on a super majority type basis
to get that additional funding through
or how would that mechanism work so
thank you representative so um a couple
things so in your question you Ed the
word
spending um maybe I'm being too
technical but to be
clear the local tax cap applies to
proposed proposed spending it's not
spending per se so with regards to your
um question with regards to
emergencies so so um to to be clear I I
would not categorize a warrant article
as emergency spending so therefore I
have to um assume that your question is
because anything that's on a warrant
can't be an emergency so I'm assuming
perhaps what you were um actually asking
had to do with like after the annual
meeting and you know the warrant
articles were V voted upon and something
came up well to be clear an emergency
like the roof fell in that that has
nothing to do with a a a local tax cap
because again this local tax cap
pertains to what the governing body can
bring to the annual meeting you need to
realize
that that's just a starting point the
meeting you know has voters and like any
other annual meeting there's NE
deliberations you know people speak for
and against and you know warrant
articles can be changed so that's what
we all need to to focus on and
remember okay so with back to the your
emergency situation and in need there's
provisions and statute that special
meeting can be held by um petitioning
the Supreme
Court you know to deal with an emergency
situation
additionally there are other statutes
that enable um contingency funds for
different things and so any good
governing body and budget committee
official budget committee if there is
one they they will you know utilize
these these budgetary tools that we have
in statute you know to plan for those
sorts of things but to answer answer
your question emergency
situations um do not pertain to a local
tax cap thank you that clarified my
situation thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative for taking my
question I I also want to compliment you
you always go into the depth that is
that really helps the conversation so I
certainly appreciate that my question is
we certainly understand that that there
was a situation in Brookline do you know
of the other and and the the methodology
says
eight different towns and school
districts they have a tax cap and they
follow it correctly so I did not reach
out to whatever research Department
there is um to to have them go and you
know check on E every you know all 10
Towns and districts that that have a
local tax cap and unfortunately I did
not have the time to do that research
myself
but if you would like um I can I can see
about the chair asking for some
research but I would also like to add
one just one District not following the
statutory
intent is is is one too
many uh represent kale in one second I
you are correct about Milton and I also
believe Rochester may or may not be
having issues in straford County
representative kill thank you Mr chair
thank you representative power for
taking my question Mr majori kind of
beat me to my question but I'll ask a
side question to that do you think you
is possible for you to get a list of all
the towns and the school districts and
the cities that are on the tax cap so we
could do that research the actual names
um thank you for the question
representative um as I had
mentioned I um had a list and then so
that I could be completely up to date I
reached out to Dr yesterday and I have
that list right here in front of me I
have the seven towns and three school
districts but to be clear a city tax cap
is under a different section of Statute
my bill only deals with um local tax cap
that can be adopted by a town or a
district do you want me to Rattle off
the towns right now that would be
fantastic actually instead we're already
well into this hearing and
um representative power can certain
to representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative power for taking my
question and for presenting this bill um
a little bit of a different kind of
question when I read the
um
325b as it is right now not with the
proposed changes it seems pretty clear
to me like really really clear to me and
I'm
wondering why you think adding more
language to what seems already clear in
the
statute would force certain towns to
change the way they do things I don't
understand how things would change
simply by changing the wording is there
some kind of enforcement mechanism is
you know how How would proposed to make
sure that what you're proposing to
happen happens thank you for the
question representative so to be clear
in my bill
introduction I laid out very
um
strenuously the problem with this bill
and it's a lot of people will just sit
here and and look at this and they
they'll they'll say
um the the budget uh you know reported
to the Dr and and and not think twice
about it but what we need to understand
is as I lay it out the budget is not the
operating budget the budget
is the operating budget plus other
warrant articles and you know then you
have to subtract off per this this RSA
which you know local revenues state aid
grant and those sorts of things so
clearly it's not just the operating
budget
so now you're asking me about
enforcement and and and you're concerned
about adding
language
well I didn't add anything with regards
to enforcement I would hope that the
people
who are on a governing body would
respect the rule of law and simply
follow statute without needing to be you
know
having enforcement mechanisms it's it's
pretty simple it's it's it's just what
people need to do they they need to
follow the law so with all due respect
even if there was an enforcement
mechanism I would say the same thing
how is that going to you know ensure
that somebody's going to follow the
statute it simply isn't because people
break laws and don't follow statutes all
day long
but there's clear and convincing
evidence that this is being
misunderstood it is being
misapplied and that's
problematic for the towns and districts
that have adopted the local tax Gap
because
in misinterpreting and misapplying the
statute and ignoring the tax cap that's
ignoring 60% of Voters that said we want
this tax cap so it's just simply a
matter of doing what is
right thank you for the questions
represent
correct yes thank you for taking my
question
um if the tax cap understand that I
don't deal with taxes at all other than
pay them so I may be off base here um if
60% of the residents have passed or
adopted a tax cap and School Board in
Brookline or Rochester or wherever is
misinterpreting
that I would would you not think that
one or two or more of the members of
that
60% would call out the school board and
say hey you're not doing what you're
supposed to be doing and if that is the
case why do we need to change the law
thank you for taking my question thank
you representative I appreciate that
question
so yes of of of course um people who are
I for lack of better words with it in
watching they should absolutely s you
know raise their hand and say hey you're
not following the tax the local tax cap
that was adopted and to be sure there
are people in Brooklyn that have done
that that are doing
that but they're
ignored Okay so what was the other part
to to to your oh you're saying why what
was the other
part um I I think you you've addressed
it by saying I think she addressed there
are people and um may ask a
followup uh yes go ahead follow
um if they are ignored why are they not
getting up and yelling and screaming and
saying you are doing this wrong we
represent 60% of the people in our town
or School District this doesn't make
sense to me okay so just to com to
answer your previous question you you
asked why
why why this bill well this bill adds
Clarity so the more clarity that we have
in
statute that's going to
inform people involved you using this
local tax cap I I just don't see how
that hurts and I can't speak if all
right so if I was on the governing Bo
board and somebody came to me and said
oh you're not following the tax cap I
would I would take a look and and I
would listen but you know everybody's
not not me so I can't really speak to
why you know people are ignored by by
governing bodies it happens all the time
it's political you're correct
representative and um just a point for
the committee try to keep the questions
because uh we are already well behind
schedule try to keep the question
specific to what the bill does um not um
arbitrary questions that really do not
deal specifically with with this further
questions for representative
power yes represent McDonald
sorry thank you Mr chairman I just got a
couple of quick question questions
they're kind of tied in together uh
capital reserve
accounts where we take money we plug
them into a capital reserve account
how's that going to show up on on your
chat here where would that where would
that
see if you look at page two this is a
form okay this is just one um
page
there eight pages to this ms26 form so
any of these Ms forums have multiple
Pages as it pertains to the local tax
cap this budget summary because I use
this as evidence to to explain what is
meant by the budget in current statute
your capital reserve account would would
would be on a different page that I
didn't um print out so it doesn't it has
nothing to do with the with the
application of the local tax cap I just
a follow yeah thank you uh now you've
got all the money saved up the LA
article and you want to go out and spend
it on new buses or a new soccer field or
something like that the the tax cap or
would it decrease the tax cap did you I
missed the first part of your question
you have you have your money saved up in
the capital reserve account and now you
want to go out and spend it a new soccer
fi the buses where is that going to show
up is that going to be included in the
tax cap or is that going to give you
more spending power for your tax
cap so in order to spend something out
of a capital reserve fund I I believe
that that would be a separate warrant
article to approve that
spending so that would that would be it
let me see would I have it I believe it
might come under the the category of
speci War special warrant
articles okay thank you for answering my
question representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
would there be an easier solution um to
have on each warrant article including
the budget warrant article a statement
by uh the select board or uh governing
body that how much
this article affects the uh taxation so
thank you for the question
representative
so I do know that there's the ability
for such a statement to to to be printed
on the warrant
article I I I can't recall if that's
something that that's
automatic or if that needs to be you
know voted upon by the legislative body
saying that you need to do that I just
not recalling at this
time representative
goth thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for your testimony uh I don't have a tax
C so I'm sort of in the black here uh
but
if it seems to me that if you add the
Articles it makes the part bigger which
gives you a better chance of having
override if there is an override and
there's say three articles that pushes
it over the 8% if that's what it is how
do you select which article you take
which article you use thank thank you
for the question representative so um
again this is not a spending cap that's
different this local tax cap is focuses
on what can your as your starting point
what can be presented or proposed at the
annual meeting it's just the starting
point but maybe to to to answer your
question it would be up to the governing
body to to order the the warrant to
order the warrant articles but again
it's not it's not a um it's not a it's
not a spending cap and I would
also maybe
include that when you have a an official
budget committee that there's a 10% rule
that the that the legislative body
cannot vote to spend more than 10% of
those warrant articles that that are
recommended by the budget
committee thank you thank you for your
answer okay are the comments questions I
I mean from the committee seeing none
thank you representative power thank you
I have two pink cards here if anybody
else intended to speak please get those
up to us uh we are going to call next uh
nhma Mr chairman may I provide a
you
and of course I handed out all my
maybe
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Katherine heck and I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and we
are here today to not refute anything of
what representative power has stated um
all of our statements have been correct
in that the tax cap the purpose of the
cap is to not exceed taxation not
spending um and that all budget and
warrant articles are included in the cap
that's correct
unfortunately based on the law on how
it's currently written the word
Appropriations has a different
definition and how we use it in New
Hampshire so I have a couple of handouts
here I did separate them out because I
think one could be very helpful not only
for this but maybe all sorts of other
testimony on how we set the municipal
tax rate and then on the back side
you'll see a fancy handy dandy chart for
how the tax rate gets set and all the
forms that we need because we talk about
this a lot in committee so I guess I
would first start by saying saying we
are governed um in in the towns that
this would apply to certainly cities as
representative stated are outside of
that they're Charters handle how the tax
cap is handled but RSA 321 through1 13
um requires gross based budgeting this
means that we disclose all
Appropriations and offsetting revenue so
the word appropriation is defined in
statute n RSA 323 so to appropriate
really means to set aside money from
public revenue and it's really the
appropriation is the purpose so it's
giving permission for a purpose the
raise the raise word is the word we
really need to focus on when we talk
about a tax cap so I think that the term
spending Taxation and appropriation when
we get into the minutia of a bill like
this um can be easily interchanged but
they could be also easily confused um so
it is important to note that the New
Hampshire Supreme Court has um ruled on
the difference the raising indicates the
source of the revenue which could be
Taxation and that's what we have to
consider in the tax cap and
appropriating um indicates how the money
will be spent so they're two separate
and distinct
items so in looking at
19 32 Frost versus to raise money
is a word that's understood to to
collect or procure a supply money for
use and to appropriate is to set apart
that public Revenue so the language to
include all Appropriations in this bill
on line three um into line four creates
a mandate to include all Appropriations
not what is to be in captured in tax
taxation so I understand the sponsor's
intent is to be sure that the law is
clear and we agree that we always want a
clear law that everyone can administer
but the word appropriation all other
appropriation would mean that we would
have to include the gross
Appropriations so if you look um at this
example on the first page you can see
how the municipal tax rate is set and
representative power did provide you um
an MS 636 or 737 so we have those gross
Appropriations we subtract Revenue we
add an overlay the veterans credits and
that equals our net Municipal tax effort
so it's really the offsetting revenues
um in the Appropriations that we have to
be concerned with to get to taxation so
again we fully agree that all individual
warrant articles with a tax impact do
have to be considered in a tax cap for
those communities but the word
appropriation itself is is the word
under current law would have to be
redefined because it's the word raise to
raise
taxation so if you look on page three I
believe of my two of two sorry of my
testimony I provided several warrant
articles and several in the language
around how this works in practice if
they're outside of the budget so in the
first example the town vote to raise and
appropriate this is all prescribed
language that we have to use by Dr so
towns must use this $330,000 for an
architectural design for a new highway
garage then you see there's four funding
sources that are going to offset that
appropriation netting no amount to be
raised in taxation so $330,000 is a
gross
appropriation and it's giving permission
to spend up to that amount for the
purpose right but the taxation itself
would not be there would be nothing to
include in a tax cap so that that would
be an example um and again I just want
to reiterate under this bill the way
it's written and how it's interpretated
by not only myself but additional
Municipal attorneys the word
appropriation would mean that we would
have to include the $30,000 in the tax
cap not not the offsetting revenue Vue
in those separate warrant articles so
we're always happy to work with the
sponsor because we would like it to be
clear on what it is um that we are
supposed to enact we certainly don't
want people not in our cities and towns
if they are not complying with the law
any effort to make that clearer we're
happy to work with but we we did want to
address that the word appropriation
itself could be interpreted to mean all
Appropriations and not any offsetting
Revenue as defined already in statute so
I'm certainly happy to take any
questions
thank you for your testimony normally I
go last I have a quick question I'm
going to ask upfront sure and that is is
is it your belief that
the RSA in question could be made more
clear and
that you would be willing to work with
the sponsor sponsors to make it more
clear that is correct we would just want
to ensure that the correct terminology
is used I do believe the way I read the
RSA it is clear but if there is a lack
of clarity in the you know and how it's
being administered it could easily say
to be um instead of all other
Appropriations that all warrant articles
with a tax impact I mean we there could
be language that that could be added if
if that is the desire of this body thank
you representative
yell thank than you that I think you
were you kind of were answering my
question I was uh looking through
your your um testimony and seeing that
you you kind of implied uh a solution
but you didn't give one it seemed to me
that striking the word appropriation and
substituting amounts raised by taxation
might alleviate your concerns um but you
just said a slightly different phrase
well I haven't worked on Amendment so it
seems like um it seems like there is an
easy fix that that you would be able to
um achieve yes thank you for your
question and I do agree that there there
could be room for language improvements
I haven't worked on those particular
Solutions at this time thank
you further questions seeing none thank
you very much for your testimony
Kleiner good morning chairman and
members of the committee and thank you
for allowing me to speak today I'm Kim
Kleiner I'm the Town Administrator from
the town of
Litchfield first let me say that the tax
cap since
2016 was adopted in the town of
Lichfield and has served us
well we are conservative committee uh
community that works to keep our taxes
low because we have a small commercial
base and most of our taxation comes from
residents we are um here today I'd like
to explain a little bit about how the
tax cap Works in
Lichfield so our selectman comes up with
an operating budget and warrant
articles and not all of those warrant
articles may fit under the tax
cap they are proposed and they go to our
official budget
committee
budget committee can only vote to
recommend articles which fit under the
tax
cap all of of our warrant articles when
they go to our
residents list the tax impact of
each so it's very clear to our residents
what the tax estimated tax impact is
because you never know until November of
that tax setting year what it really
is they are very clear as to what the
estimated tax impact is
also our official budget committee May
lower our operating budget during their
review in order to recommend a warrant
appropriate our legislative body our
voters are by Statute the ones that can
override the cap and sometimes they may
feel it necessary to do
so so there may be a propos osed warrant
article not recommended by our official
budget
committee that the voters choose to
adopt and by
Statute and we feel it is their right to
do so if they feel it warrant Our
concern um um a little bit with the
proposed bill as is is the word
appropriation um as a previous spoke
speaker spoke to
so an
appropriation especially as defined on a
warrant article does not necessarily
mean
taxation um they two they are two
entirely different
things um and let me read you an article
that is coming up for our town
meeting um article 8 it's going to
establish a recreational a recreation
Expendable trust fund right so we we
have recreational buildings in our town
that are in need of repair and our
Selectmen and our budget committee feel
it's time to set some money
aside to see if the town will vote to
establish a recreational Expendable
trust fund for the maintenance and
repair of Recreational Equipment
facilities systems and to raise and
appropriate the sum of $25,000 to be
placed in such
fund further to name the selectman as
the agents to expend this sum is to come
from the unassigned fund
balance and no amount to be raised from
taxation so we are
asking for the voters to approve the
appropriation to be able to spend but
it's coming from the unassigned fund
balance so there's no amount to be
raised from new
taxation so therefore our official
budget committee that must only
recommend articles that are beneath the
cap can vote to approve or recommend if
they see
fit it's very important that for
Lichfield who has been very very
conscious of our local tax cap and we're
very careful to answer all of our
residents questions on what the
estimated tax impact will
be on how their tax taxes will come out
the following year it's very important
that we are clear with our
residents for communities that may have
um difficulties in understanding the tax
cap there are plenty of communities or
committees and agencies sees the Dr
being the best that can help to assist
them but the word
appropriation does not necessarily mean
Taxation and for our
community we feel that needs to be very
clear thank you I think between yourself
and and Miss HEC you made that point
abundantly clear are there any uh
representative
Holland thank you this is another like
since you have a real life example of
doing this and I don't really understand
tax caps so have you ever had an example
where you had a community petitioned
warrant placed on there that so someone
says we need $500,000 theoretically for
this and they petition they put the
warrant to be placed on the ballot how
does the official budget committee do
they make a recommendation on it saying
like no we think this will exceed the
tax cap and this is a bad idea or they
not comment and you know how does that
work thank you for the question um in my
time I have not seen um a petition or an
article come forward that went over the
tax cap or had a or even had a budget
impact or taxation impact um but our
budget committee is very clear and they
would not recommend anything that would
cap uh represent Bri thanks for taking
my question uh just quickly I think one
of the there's two things that I want to
get clarified I appreciate you
clarifying the clarifying example about
the article 8 and how that would work
but you said that voters can override
the cap um in town meeting basically and
how does that uh affect the 60% of the
people or the super majority that had
already said we want a tax cap how's
that
work thank you thank you so by placing
the estimated tax in impact on your
warrant
articles um you're giving your voters
the realization of what will exceed the
cap right they know what the cap is if
it's not recommended by the budget
committee it most likely goes over the
cap that's the main reason for having
that it's clearly on the warrant they
clearly understand that it goes over the
cap because it's not recommended by the
official budget committee
quickly follow up yep so you're saying
that a regular vote in town meeting can
override the 60% of people who don't
want that the the amount of the taxation
8% so to be honest thank you for the
question but how
would by Statute the legislative body
can override the cap how would that ever
happen if it wasn't on the warrant to
begin with um other than a petition
warrant article um sometimes there are
such issues that come up within your
town that you our
Selectmen make the decision that it
should be at least placed forward to the
voters for them to
decide again they would see the tax
impact of such a vote and they would see
that it was not recommended by the
budget committee and the voters could
vote does anybody else have any
questions that are gerain to the bill
already representative PRI thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question it's my understanding that
under this proposed
legislation all warant articles would be
prohibited for even consideration in a
budget committee if it would if they
were deemed to be over the
8%
capk that is that correct that is that
well okay thank you seeing no
more questions from the committee and
having no more pink cards we will go and
1105 uh for those who were supposed to
start at 10:20 and 10:40 apologies once
again for the
chairman not estimating the time of the
first one
appropriately uh we will go ahead now
and open up the hearing on hp1 1461
relative to live streaming of all proper
all properly noticed meetings and
hearings and I believe the Prime sponsor
morning thank you chairman kirot and
thank you committee members for your
time and interest for the record I'm
representative Pope Damon I represents
Sullivan District 88 which is a nin
toown floal serves the beautiful Sugar
River communities of are you ready
aworth Goan Langdon lemster Springfield
sopy Washington my hometown of Cen and
the City of
Claremont hb1 1461 would require
communities to record and live stream
all publicly posted Municipal meetings
this is the improved version of last
year's HB 295 which was tabled 1461
would create a permanent record of of
Select board city council school board
and other local government meetings most
importantly the legislation will provide
the same accessibility transparency and
accountability that YouTube streaming
and recording of our state legislature
proceedings and executive Council now
routinely makes available while live
streaming does currently happen in many
communities It Is by no means Universal
in New
Hampshire please note this is not
legislation to require remote
participation a in Municipal meetings it
is simply live streaming in real time so
citizens can observe democracy and then
archive the meetings for reference these
recordings will not replace traditional
meeting minutes but will serve as
another document of the
proceedings making our local government
process more visible can increase trust
in the work of our dedicated elected
officials by inviting greater citizen
awareness we can improve decision making
and enhanced community relations it
likely has future benefit of increasing
candidates for local positions perhaps
it even creates greater appreciation of
the work of elected
officials you understandably may ask why
is this needed as people can attend
these public meetings it's not so easy
for many many elderly folks who no
longer Drive must be selective about how
often they ask for assistance getting
places we need to engage their voices
and benefit from their accumulated
experience for parents of young children
early evening meetings so common in
local government are very difficult
childcare is expensive and often just
simply not available we need to hear the
voices of these parents their children
are the future of our
democracy people with physical
limitations May simply find it too
complicated to participate in person and
finally making meetings remotely
accessible is better for for our
Collective public health for those who
might question how many citizens would
actually watch I note these
anecdotes when I was initially
campaigning in 2022 for State Rep in
Claremont where I was not well known at
the time I attended a city council
meeting and unintentionally chose a seat
that was on camera often next day as I
was door knocking multiple people told
me they had seen and heard me the night
before I decided to own that seat for
future meetings the there is a lot of
citizen participation in watching live
stream meetings in the communities that
currently do
that last year when the cyon school
board was scheduling a budget hearing
the site was chosen to best accommodate
live streaming after our school budget
cut was our school budget was cut by 53%
in a poorly attended 2022 school meeting
a volunteer stepped up to record and
stream most meetings people have come to
expect and appreciate shate streaming
meetings that volunteer now serves on
our select
board so there are challenges is
broadband adequate you might ask
according to the nhma website there are
only three New Hampshire communities
that do not have Broadband the bill does
address that also the New Hampshire
Broadband mapping initiative reports
that as of June 30th
2023 95% of the New Hampshire population
has Broadband access so folks can tune
in please note there is exemption to the
streaming requirement when technological
challenges
occur in most communities the
requirements of this proposed statute
can be done for a very modest cost that
I believe is appropriate for the values
I have
noted for those who don't have Broadband
satellite services such as starlink have
a one-time Hardware cost of about $600
with a reasonable monthly fee of
$110 a camera and microphone setup can
be purchased for less than
$2,000 or what we started with initially
in cin as basic as one board member sets
up a zoom or Google meets on a laptop
not perfect quality but available
affordable and much appreciated by
voters there are also companies such as
Town Hall streaming who will contract to
provide this
Service Hardware is free with a monthly
subscription fee depending on the number
of meetings being recorded but it's in
the range of $100 to $200 per month I
learned about town hall streaming from
the sunap town manager and then also
heard about it from do and both
indicated they're very pleased with this
service currently there's at least 30
New Hampshire municipalities Contracting
with that
company critics might argue that
underinformative is the last thing that
local government needs right now I
believe this under estimates the
intelligence of citizens and is an old
excuse for conducting the business of
local government in the dark with a
little bit of nudging from state
government it will be good to see all
municipalities working in the full gaze
of the public eye if we value citizen
participation informed voters and a fair
Democratic process you will vote OTP on
House Bill
1461 to improve transparency in local
government thank you for your
consideration and I will try to answer
any questions representative kahill
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question do you think
that this would be an unfunded mandate
and should be decided at the local level
thank you for the question and I think
we have address that in the bills so if
you bear with me so I get the right copy
of the bill
here
on lines 2 2 through
um would require municipalities to raise
a warrant article to raise and
appropriate the funds however line
26-28 that expenditure would be S
submitted to the state for reimbursement
from the general fund so it's not an
hi um thanks for filing this bill um
so uh one thing I'm wondering about uh
you mentioned uh YouTube and a number of
other
services um
so I I'm wondering um so if a
municipality relies on one of these
external
Services um for its live streaming and
there's a problem on the service
providers and like
say
um say the service provider has an
outage or um restricts the town's
account or
something um what would
um would would um would the municipality
be held liable in that case or would
there be a way to hold the provider
liable um
for this for um this failure to
stream thank you for the question um so
there is a
statement uh lines 13 to
15 um if there are adverse circumstances
the chair of the P public body will
acknowledge the reason for not live
streaming or recording recorded and it
will be noted in the minutes so if it's
a power outage
or you needed to hold the meeting in a
different location maybe for different
capacity or you were on site at a I
don't know a bridge celebration or
something it wouldn't be required it
would just be you know document why
um I frankly have not thought about the
consideration of if it's an external
service and it
fails what the responsibility or
liability is I think I should research
that and frankly find out what are we
happens do you have a follow-up rep G
yeah um well so
um so yeah the part from lines 13 to 15
um is good um I was wondering more
though about um line five um on a
platform that is accessible to the
general public um I was wondering um if
you could talk more about um what you
consider the definition of accessible to
be and
um so one of my um major issues for
example is um software Freedom advocacy
so I I generally oppose proprietary
software and would see
um
requiring these representative Gallagher
um yeah this is leading into a question
um I State the question please yeah so
um and would would see that as um the
requirement to use proprietary software
to be inaccessible so would you see that
as um would would your definition of uh
inaccess accessibility um cover that
question it may be that we need to add a
definition of accessibility into the
bills so that it's not
ambiguous um and I would be very open to
discussing that further with you or
others who might have more expertise on
that than I do representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for your efforts to make
transparency a thing in every community
and and I I'm a selectman so it is a
goal uh but my question is what it what
do you uh identify as meetings it this
says that you would that this activity
would have to be in all meetings we have
meetings in most communities that uh sub
subcommittees of another committee that
are held uh in another room if you will
I mean depending on what the
availability of space is uh we have
people we have meetings that I don't I
guess when your your three Selectmen get
together uh if it's f a five member
board that's a meeting do you you want
to have that you know all this uh this
kind of activity be uh
required uh makes it a little you know
concern to me and particularly when you
I see all through the bill the word
shell that's a red flag to
me but I can the real question is what
do you what determines a
meeting thank you for the good question
so in line four when it specifies
properly notic so the intent is if it's
a posted public government
meeting then it is obligated should this
bill pass to be live streamed unless
there is some exceptional circumstance
that is noted in the minutes I
appreciate
the
consideration that if you have meetings
occurring uh at the same time and maybe
your
service whether it's provided by the
community or external service might be
only in some part of a building and not
in every meeting
room
um
my preference would be that we stream it
all that we see select board City
Council planning board zoning board at
if it's a publicly posted meeting
citizens should be able to see what's
going
said represent D I think you've answered
the question can I just one sense
quickly please I would be open to
negotiating a priority setting
if need be to address competing
meetings uh representive FR I saw your
before thank you for taking my question
um I want to make sure that I understand
the mechanics of funding this from the
point of view of the
Town um Roman numeral 8 says that
municipality shall present a warrant
article uh to raise and appropriate
funds for the purpose of providing live
broadcast etc
etc um going back perhaps to the
definition of raise and appropriate from
the previous bill that we were
discussing um would I be correct in
assuming that the warrant article would
say raise and appropriate X number of
dollars to be to be reimbursed by state
funds yes and uh follow-up question
representative yes please I'm Sor
followup um when that reimbursement is
made by the state where does that money
go where in
the I'm operating on the expectation
that the municipality
has well either they have expended the
funds
to start doing this prior to receiving
the expected reimbursement and so it
would go into the town general fund or
they're waiting to implement it until
they receive it and it's still going in
the town General funds thank you for
answering my question thank you
representa
Ella thank you thank you for taking the
question
um I
imagine the possibility of someone at
the
municipality going down to their
local uh phone store and buying a phone
with an unlimited plan and could
possibly use that to just live stream or
a municipality could spend
$100,000 outfitting their building with
a lot of different um uh the highest
grade technology as far as uh technology
uh for live streaming and nothing in
your
uh uh uh Bill directs them or limits
them or in any way incentivize them to
do a more lower budget option if someone
else is paying for it and not the
taxpayers so would you be um in favor of
do of setting some limit like let's
say $55,000 or $10,000 is the maximum um
allowed for such a warrant article uh so
that the estate is not on the hook for
essentially 100,000 times as many towns
as there
are thank you thank you for the very
good question I'm chagrined that I
didn't think of that in um having the
bill drafted and looked at and yes I
would be very open to an amendment um we
just need to figure out what the
appropriate cap would
be representative majority
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question um
I I just first of all I I certainly
support the intent of what you wanted to
do and my town you can't sneeze in my
town without it being recorded somewhere
um and put on something so that's good I
like that but I don't don't fully
understand Roman 2 a body or an agency
has a meeting if they don't have a
website it needs to go to the relevant
town can you explain what that what
Roman 2 means yes thank you for the
question um that was actually by
recommendation of os that a community
likely has a website as I not well not
sure if I did say that but most do but
an individual body say a planning board
may not have their own website so the
recording of a planning board meeting
would go on the town website not on an
individual planning board website in
that case
is that make sense yes thank
representative kahill thank you Mr J
thank you for taking another question so
under your verified expenditure do you
see that including labor costs for
this I would say no because the labor
cost is
negligible you're at a meeting and
you're going to open the laptop or
you're going to like with Town Hall
streaming you literally flick a switch
so I'm not sure what labor is
involved quick follow up quickly please
yes well wouldn't you have to pay
someone to be
there to operate it's a public meeting
so people will be there the people who
are are the board or the
agency representative a sorry I missed
you before thank you Mr chairman thank
you hope for um um representative Damon
for coming here today because I'm very
interested in your bill as you know um
my question is did you obtain
information as to how many
municipalities already live stream I
think we have what 204
municipalities so I
tried I did not
find a like in one place piece of data
that said this many towns live stream
I actually went through and looked
up um not all 200 I think I got through
about 150 to see how many had websites
and I I think I found four that didn't
so that's an
inexact you know anecdotal report but
it's very limited that there aren't
websites at
all follow M yes go ahead um I'm sorry I
wasn't clear I meant how many towns live
stream currently oh sorry different
answer um there's 30-some live streaming
through town hall streaming there are
quite a few others who are streaming in
other
ways bear with me one moment I have a
list um actually I don't it's in my bag
and Ed committee I can get back to you
about that and what you could do is send
that to the committee as a whole and
that way we'd have the numbers
representative
uh
stavis thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
I'd like to go back to Roman numeral
Roman numeral 2 for a moment um would
you be amendable to amending that
language so that it's more
specific such as
meetings minutes of meetings where live
streaming is not possible shall be
posted within 72 hours of the completion
of the
meeting on the public body's website
because as it stands right now it's just
recordings shall be posted well what
recordings
why at what point of when the meeting is
you know just seems to need a little bit
more specificity there and I Mr Sheriff
I may have brief follow up
yes what
happens if in
what happens if the money is not
fund if the bill
passes as that funding part is
written how would the state not
reimburse it am I allowed to answer a
question with a question you may and you
did a very good job further questions
representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question I
I I have um I'm wondering why the
recording shall be posted within 72
hours when um a regular public meeting
of any government governing body um has
five days to prepare their
minutes that's an excellent question and
it should probably be consistent so how
many amendments have I agreed to so
far followup Mr chair follow up yes go
ahead um also uh perhaps this should be
amended to uh reference section 33- a um
RSA 33- a because it does um list how
long to keep records would that be a
place to also mention these need to be
kept uh
permanently thank you for that
question there was discussion and Frank
I think it got overlooked in the process
um to make that consistent with how long
uh standard minutes are
archived if I may back up to your first
question it's less work to post a video
recording than it is to
finish the uh traditional
minutes if people are more comfortable
with it or it's less confusing I would
certainly entertain making it 5 days but
unreasonable see no representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question this is kind
of a clarification a couple of the other
questions so how many municipalities
currently do not have live streaming I
might have missed that someplace in the
testimony so was asked how many do so
either way and I'm going to get back to
the committee with as representative
Damon that that is going to be presented
sen Amon is already going to send that
to us thank you one one quick followup
followup
so Representatives on my left asked some
questions about the estimated cost
annual cost um I would I would like to
see in in the followup to this estimated
total annual cost on on similar types of
things that you mentioned in your verbal
discussion about uh minimum basic system
you know a kind of standard standard
system and uh kind of some followup with
maybe
few of the people that testified last
year about it being a burden on some of
you okay um I can provide followup that
wasn't a question right that was not was
a request yes I certainly and the data
that I have I have copies of my remarks
for you but we can be more extensive
than
that okay seeing no more questions from
the committee uh thank you for your
testimony going to call Representative
representative cluder and those to
follow I would ask if something has
already been uh discuss please dispense
with it we are way behind already okay
best you can because represent D in the
prime made a fabulous presentation and
I'm representative John cluder from
Sullivan County district 6 which
comprises the communities of Claremont
and cuden and I'm here today in strong
support of House Bill
1461 I was a co-sponsor of a similar
Bill to 295 which was uh tabled because
of some various concerns and for some
reason I didn't sign up on the list in
time but I still believe strongly in the
in the principle of this bill and I
think representative Damon laid it out
well the only thing I want to elaborate
is in Claremont we've had Public Access
for over 20 years now and actually we're
pretty late uh late than in comparison
to some Sullivan County communities I
think the oldest has the community in
Sullivan County that's had public asset
longest in Newport and they do a good
job in Newport and I think Claremont
they're doing a good job too and like
representative Damon people watch it I
mean first I was skeptical how many of
my constituents are going to be watching
Public Access but I had as a State Rep I
sometimes brief the city council and the
school board and I I one day I remember
short going grocery shopping and people
start tell hey I saw you on TV and I
said where did you see me on Channel 9
or whatever no it was public access so
people in my opinion from watch it and I
think it has fabulously got more PE
citizens interested in government and
I'm glad the City of Claremont went
forward on that but I want cuden the
other community to have that same
opportunity that we in in Claremont have
now and so I really strongly believe in
this bill I believe it has been uh
amended to take care of some of the
concerns being an unfunded mandate
you'll notice the effective date takes
effect on July 1st 2025 the same time as
our next state budget so there should be
we should prepare next year depending on
what happens with if this bill becomes
law to allocate some money to reimburse
our communities I know there's a lot of
communities that already have it so
they're not going to be out like
Claremont we're not going to we don't
need it we need but Clen really needs it
and several other
communities um and so I think we really
need to do that uh the only thing if I
you know with all due respect to the
represent Dame and the sponsors I notice
it's written for just Municipal meetings
I'm surprised it doesn't talk about
school meetings and that's you know
school district meetings which is just
as important so if I had do you know
suggestion for amendments I'd maybe
include school meetings as well uh but I
think the right to no law is very
important and I think this is just
extends the right to no law and makes
government more accountable and
accessible to ordinary citizens some of
whom are just busy trying to make a
living taking care of kids some of whom
are also are handicapped or senior
citizens who cannot get out easily
especially on these cold winter nights
so I strongly urge this committee to
work with the with me and the other spon
representative Dame and the other
sponsors to pass some version of this
bill out of the committee and give
people in especially in our smaller
communities the same chance of having
public access to their local government
as people in larger communities like
Claremont and Newport have thank you
very much Mr chairman members of the
committee representative
lales yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative cluder I
noticed the in Roman
five it says that the bill does not
mandate remote participation
so if if so it's it's a
oneway uh situation so somebody can
observe the meeting but uh they're not
able to provide input is that correct
well okay what I know from Claremont I
think right now Claremont if you want to
come to a city council or school board
meeting you've got to come if you want
to address the city council because we
have citizen agenda or other things you
have to come and address the city
Council or the school board I think
though during the pandemic that rule was
somewhat relaxed so that people could
call in with questions or but normally
we have Public Access meetings are
televised people can watch them at home
but if they want to come and ask
questions of their City counselors or
city officials or make statements
they've got to come in person and
testify this is the way the City of
Claremont does it I can't speak for
other communities so I don't have a
problem with this provision because it
goes on in Claremont right now so
hopefully they have answered your
question followup Mr
chairman the other the other thing that
certainly the way people get their news
has changed
significantly in some ways it's positive
because you have access to almost
anything yeah but in some ways it's
negative because because you come to
depend upon that uh for we have in my
town we have a number of people who are
uh particularly elderly people who do
not have access to the internet in their
home I'm just wondering if this would be
an opportune time to make some provision
for those folks to come to the town hall
for instance and access whatever channel
the town is is uh the the the town
website or whatever so they could look
at the minutes and they could watch the
meeting uh if it's of particular
interest to
them an objection to it would be up to
the community but if they want to come
to the town hall and and use a computer
that's fine uh and and look at meeting
minutes which are very you know
important to some people and meeting
minutes obviously it's not going to
abolish meeting minutes this bill and
shouldn't but of course for for people I
think being being able to watch a
meeting sometimes is easier than reading
reading minutes and they can see the the
personalities who people are get to know
their Community uh I mean I'm open to
doing other uh some of the stuff that
you might have uh considered because I
know for our senior citizens especially
and I I'm 66 years old and I'm obviously
gotten used to this technology but I
tell younger people I didn't grow up and
there's a lot of people didn't grow up
with it so you got to bear with us and
things are changing but I think we've
got to try to change with the times
including government including our local
governments state governments Etc and
representative I think sorry about that
answer the question okay so hopefully I
answered your question thank you Mr CH
repr Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative taking my question uh
I know we've talked about um funding and
uh since you're familiar with Claremont
and you understand of what it costs and
where the trouble is um do you know and
I'm going to put you on the spot but
don't take it personally sure do you
know um of a a community like mine that
splits the franchise fee from the local
uh provider uh cable provider so that we
can pay for our uh
I Claremont we have com Comcast as our
provider I believe the city gets some
money from Comcast that helps pay for
our Public Access station uh I just
don't know the amount I mean it helps
reduce the the amount of taxes so I
think it's little or nothing on the
actual proper I can't swear to it but I
believe they they use the Comcast fee uh
directly or indirectly to help pay for
the public access that the the City of
Claremont
provides thank you seeing no more
questions thank you for your testimony
donelly
thank you there we
go and just pull it a little closer to
him how's that how's that good excellent
thank you uh thank you very much uh for
the record my name is Ryan Donnelly I am
an advocacy coordinator with Granite
State Independent Living tsil is a
Statewide nonprofit organization that
Advocates and provides services for
seniors and people with disabilities who
want to remain independent in their
homes and communities and uh I will make
my comments brief there's already been
uh a lot of great discussion and
testimony on this but uh just really
wanted to take a moment to stress the uh
very positive potential that this could
have for uh seniors and people with
disabilities who may have a great
interest in the business of local
government but for a variety of reasons
just aren't able to make it to uh public
meetings and town hearings in person uh
I am very fortunate to be able to have a
vehicle that I can drive myself and
folks to provide personal care that I
need to uh get dressed and get ready for
my day and all that but uh I I really am
the exception in the state I would say
and there are there are a lot of folks
who for new fault of their own uh just
have a very hard time or just can't get
out of their house and would like to
know what's going on in their towns and
you know what their elected officials
are doing and I can tell you in my
advocacy work where I follow a lot of
what goes on right here in the lob in
the state house and all that being able
to uh watch public hearings and work
sessions and exact sessions and all of
that online on YouTube has been just so
incredible for me I literally I mean I
wouldn't be able to do my work without
it to be able to come here every day be
at all the hearings and and all that so
uh you know I understand there are
concerns around technical aspects and
where the money's going to come from and
all that but I really do think this is a
a worthwhile investment and it's it's
going to help everybody not just people
with disabilities but you know folks
with small kids and or folks who work
odd hours who uh want want to be engaged
in their in their communities so I hope
you will give this legislation some some
very serious consideration because I
think I think it's the way forward and
uh thank you happy to take any any
questions you might
have thank you for your testimony seeing
no questions we will go to the next uh I
just saw Nate run out of the room
representative I mean uh Katherine heck
are you g to in in his stad
heck and I failed to mention at the
beginning of the meeting uh anybody who
test a uh testifies could you please at
the beginning of your testimony uh say
whether you're for or against or neutral
we know what you're doing up here with
the pink cards but the members of the
audience do
not good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Katherine heck and I represent the
New Hampshire Municipal Association I am
going to be brief as I'm testifying for
my colleague who has copious notes that
I can't
read but but in following along and
understanding our positions um we
certainly are concerned around this bill
because as it was already asked what the
cost would be because there could be
certainly a varied array of costs and it
would have to be um accessible and a da
compliance so there's definitely some
very specific costs around ensuring that
it meets those compliance standards um
in addition to which creates an
appropriation or an expenditure in this
bill or any kind of dedicated fund for
this so we are also concerned around how
that that piece might work but it sounds
like there's um some discussion about
some amendments so I'm certain we can
reach out to the sponsor and see where
we can um clear things up on our
side thank you representative
P thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so um you had in
your testimony you mentioned that um you
were concerned about the costs of
implementation and you referenced ADA
Compliant I I'm I'm not making the
connection there with what that
accessible materials available to the
public represent kill thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so
our governor can veto bills is our
governor authorized to not can he say no
to this can he say no when he's
authorized to draw the warrant for said
sum is it possible for the governor to
say no does he have the the authority to
do that so my understanding is that this
would um ultimately go through governor
and Council if the governor's authorized
to draw warrant so it would be up to
their purview to decide if those costs
were or were not eligible um and there's
not really anything in the B to your
point may I ask Margaret Burns to come
up and answer that question as I am not
an expert in the right to Noah I'm I do
apologize hi there good morning I'm
Margaret burns the executive director of
the New Hampshire Municipal association
with your respect with respect to your
question representative stavis I don't
think the um posting of live stream
meetings would contradict that provision
at all that provision is meant to make
it clear to members of boards that you
are not allowed to email around or use
the telephone or text messages in order
to have conversations about business
that relates to your board or committee
and that that is not a way to sort of do
an end run around the requirement that
public business be conducted in front of
the public um that sort of one a string
of one-on-one Communications among board
members using electronic means is not
permitted follow up just to be clear I
was my premise was the 91a supports this
bill oh
okay that that in the the provisions of
91a seem to demand what's being
suggested in this bill I do not read
that provision to require that I read
that as I said to be a Prohibition on
those out of meeting Communications
using digital or other um purposes sorry
for under misunderstanding your question
repres uh yella thank you uh I think uh
we need a little bit more clarification
on what 91a is talking about there I
believe um would you believe that the uh
that 91a is talking about um board
members um attending a meeting remotely
and that they need to contemporary
contemporaneously talk and speak to
um uh the public and the other board
members um if they're participating
remotely and this bill is talking about
um just remote uh viewership and not
attending they wouldn't be attending the
meeting according to the law or the bill
in question I do believe that this bill
in question has to does not have to do
with that provision of the right to no
law and instead has to do with the
meeting itself being streamed as it's
being conducted without having any
impact on whether board members or the
public attend virtually I believe it is
issues representative Gallagher um
so uh continuing or to go a bit further
on the 91a question so um
the 91a is meant to be the um law that
implements the section of the
Constitution that guarantees a right to
transparency so
um even if you think there's a
difference between 91a specifically
would it still be in keeping with the um
right to transparency from the
Constitution
though is the question does this is this
bill as proposed consistent with the
requirement in the Constitution I
apologize I'm not an understanding the
question um all
well I I was
just B basically I was just reasing
Representatives SA question except
substituting uh article 8 the right of
um transparency in the Constitution for
91a representative Galler I I think
we're getting a little bit far field on
that I don't think this bill impacts
that I I think it does I think this is
about transparency it's about um
providing representa
gallager
um we're going to we're going to hold
that your your point you can make those
points when we get to the executive
session but I I I do not believe that
what what you're stating impacts this
bill this bill is quite a bit different
than I think the road you're traveling
lales yes thank you and I I just wanted
to uh take advantage of you folks while
you're here providing
testimony do you know if all towns
in the state have access are uh cabled
hardwired
cabled uh are are all towns uh and I'm
not talking about individual residences
are all towns cabled no they are not and
I think it's important to as a as an
attachment to that question that many
towns their select boards their various
boards are holding their meetings in Old
buildings many of which do not have any
of the capabilities necessary for
streaming so that is an important
implication of the Mandate that is
included in this
Bell followup go ahead chairman um do
you know how many towns do not have uh
are not cabled I don't know that number
off the top of my head I don't know if
Catherine has a better sense we can
confirm that there are five communities
but there could be several more that do
not currently have the ability to adhere
to any type of live streaming they're
still using dialup or some other
Antiquated type of internet and they
also don't maintain a website for that
reason so we do have some of our other
um even more remote locations that we
have not been able to 100% confirm or
not confirm whether they can would be
able to adhere to the requirement of
live streaming because that takes a lot
of bandwidth for the live streaming
piece thank you thank you any further
questions before you run I have one that
I actually meant to ask representative
Damon uh on line 26 based on what's in
this bill you can do this with a yes or
no for me Katherine um can you tell me
what a verified expenditure is I cannot
thank
you f questions seeing none thank you
very much I have no more pink cards on
this bill had a blue sheet with one Con
on
it and with that we will close the
hearing on hb1 1461 and immediately open
1708 relative to local records
retentions and I see the prime sponsor
representative yella is taking the stand
the floor is
yours thank you Mr chair and members of
the
committee I'm here today to introduce HB
1708 FN uh
regarding uh the local records
retention um kind of on the same theme
as we've been talking about this morning
um government
transparency and access um is very
important both in our Constitution and
in um our laws and I think that
um getting more
um records digitally um increases and
access to them uh uh you know online
increases that uh
transparency and in large part the law
already allows for municipalities to
have digital um records and to um
display them to the public it doesn't um
and even destroy the originals if
they're keeping a digital copy um as
long as they're accessible um and
however most municipalities are not
doing so
um and one of and this bill is
essentially to uh encourage
municipalities and not mandate them to
do so through facilitating of um the
state
to uh creating um a
website that would host these public
records and essentially take the burden
off of those municipalities once the um
electronic records are uploaded to that
website so then they would be the
responsibility of the state to fulfill
that access requirement and no longer
the
municipality um currently in law there's
already
uh a person that was put in into law uh
it's I believe they're called the local
government records manager that was
never funded um they were essentially
uh put in place to help advise and and
uh support these the the public access
uh to the records and what I'm proposing
this legislation is to fund that
position hire that person and have one
of the tasks be that they create a
website that um
municipalities can upload those public
documents to or records too and
that once uploaded th they that the
municipality would no longer be on the
hook for fulfilling those 91a requests
um provided that um the that local
municipality
uh uh provides the public at least one
cost-free method of accessing the
website in their in their
municipality um
and uh I also passed out uh an amendment
earlier this morning uh Amendment
005 which just fixes s issue as far as
when the money for the um the
appropriation would lapse um it was in
the current bill on line four it's set
to elapse on June 30th of this year and
we are just switching that to J June
30th of the following year
2025 I'm happy to answer any questions
however the
um uh there is you know there there are
stakeholders that are present including
the municipal County Association the
Secretary of State's office and the
state archist that are here um that I
worked with as far as drafting this this
legislation and they might be able to
answer more technical implementation
questions thank you thank you
representative Ella any questions of
Representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
on page two of the the bill and I know
you have a an amendment but I'm going to
still speak to page two so on lines 10
and 12 my question is what happens if
there's no money in the um
treasury um for this purpose is that a
possibility and if it is what what would
happen then thank
believe I I spoke with the speaker
before putting this bill in and
they the speaker gave me a dollar figure
that would be inappropriate to put
forward and this the the needs of this
bill was not not an excess of that and
so I believe that there may be
um f
um extra funds that have uh been
unanticipated uh revenues of the of the
state that that have not currently been
attributed to any any amount but that
that would obviously be handled by
finance and not the this committee thank
you for the
question representative gallager go
ahead um
so you're noting how both this and the
previous Bill had to do with
transparency one of the um
previous one of the questions for the
previous bill was um if there would have
to be staff involved well so if both
this bill and the previous bill passed
would the staff provided for by this
bill be able to be used as staff for the
previous
Bill thank you for the question
um the staff in this is staff at the
state
archive um and so they the and and
specifically for the record um the money
goes to one creating the website and two
for fun to hire the person um the local
records manager um the local records
manager um would not be uploading
documents local local documents to the
however in a different sense the website
theoretically could be used
to to house
the any document that or any any file
that was a public record so if that
happened to be a video file
theoretically that could also be housed
on the
website but that
the Technic the technical capabilities
of the website um you know will be
speced out by the archivist and
representative go thank you for the yes
thank you Mr chairman I it isn't clear
to me what whether or not any local
records will be kept by this
C or is it just the state
records thank you for the question this
is about the ability for local
municipalities to upload the their local
records to the State website and then
the responsibility for the for the
access under 91a would be relieved from
the municipality essentially saving the
municipality money of of fulfilling
those 91a requests and it would be
placed on the
state and be fulfilled by the access to
the website follow up Mr
chairman follow up
I concerned about whether or not it's on
fund a mandate unintentionally because
of the work that the local uh
municipalities will have to do to get
these records into the state thank you
for the followup that is not uh an
unfunded mandate because nothing in this
bill is required those municipalities
don't have to upload the documents the
benefit of uploading the documents is it
saves them money in the future for
having to fulfill the 91a requests right
now if they don't upload those documents
then they would have to fulfill those
91a request and and you know that can be
upwards of um uh $60,000 was was one one
uh number quoted to me about a a right
to no request that could be um
alleviated by the uploading of that
document to the to the um website in
this B thank you thank you thank you Mr
G represent s thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question I am
wondering about lines 26 and
27 um if electronic Municipal records
are stored in this manner no additional
copy need be kept by the municipality if
the municipality provides the public at
least one cost-free method of accessing
the website we just had a very long
conversation about the costs of
Technology how would you guarantee a
cost-free method of accessing the
website to the general
public thank you for the
question
that that could be the local library it
could be uh
a computer with internet accessibility
at the town website it
it all that this Bill is saying is if
you give the M the town this costree
method of accessing the website then you
can uh then you don't have to keep those
those
uh Records non-electronically at your at
your uh municipality and so it's not
requiring that they that they give that
it's just saying if you do then you can
do this other thing thank you for the
question well follow go ahead thank you
Mr chair um with respect you just said
something about the municipality but it
is a requirement of this bill that the
municipality provide the public with at
least one cost-free method of accessing
the website how would you guarantee that
level maybe I'm misunderstanding the
question because there is no
requirement in the bill
that the
municipality provide the public at least
one costree method of accessing the
website it says if on line 16 right in
the middle it says if if if the
municipality does so then they can do
this but if they don't then they can't
do it so it's not a requirement it's a
choice by the municipality whether they
choose to or not thank you for the
question representative Brown thank you
Mr chairman uh represent Rio I guess uh
the question I have really is so this
moving forward would alleviate townships
from having to
provide from having to keep any hard
copy records everything would be
electronic and then they could go to the
archive is that the case thank you for
the question that is really up to the
municipality if they fully
implement the this to the fullest
capabilities that is possible then yes
however um I'm not sure that that they
would it would be easy for them to go to
the full extent because let's say your
emails are technically covered under
right to know but are they going is is
the municipality going to gather up all
of those emails and put them on on the
website so that they don't have to
fulfill any right to no requests on that
maybe maybe not um but any any documents
that they put on the website then they
would be be free from so any investment
that they made as far as like we're
going to put up the town meeting minutes
or we're going to put the select minutes
or whatever the case may be it that
translate into a benefit to for all
future time that they no no longer have
to uh fulfill the right to no request
for that those documents but thank you
for the question follow up Mr chairman
follow
up
I'll get this right so basically um this
could potentially save townships from
having to have large stor storage areas
of documents like most towns currently
have and they have to maintain those as
well so this in alarm could save
significant money for towns right thank
you for the question yes that that was
the purpose of the bill is to make it a
win-win win as far as um the
municipality has less um um ongoing kind
of liabilities for right to no requests
and the the the people get more access
and um that it costs less money overall
because like I said before each request
requires additional time from for the
the town's people to fulfill those right
to no requests whereas if they were just
on the website it could um it could be
accessed much more frequently and at a
much lower cost to each each right to no
request essentially thank you thank you
repr
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
you've been many of the questions have
been about the uh 91a right to know uh
law yes um my question is a couple years
ago we established the right to know
edsman um do you think that this uh new
position or new
technique would uh uh make that position
unnecessary and therefore the money
could go into this new
position thank you for the question if
there was 100% adoption across the high
entire
State uh and essentially no municipality
had any local records that they were in
charge of keeping and and it was all up
to the state than possibly but I think
that is an unlikelihood in the near
future but thank you for the question
FR yes thank you for taking my question
um if I as a citizen am making a records
request from the
website are you basically just requiring
that the citizen be given the web
address address and you turn him free or
you know what someone who does
not know how to search a database is
going to be totally lost so how is this
more
transparent thank you for the question
um yes online
um online
uh one two and three of page
two amends 9 1 a to say if you if you've
uploaded it in accordance with this
provision that you that you're
essentially fulfilling the right to no
request by providing that Dain domain
name um and and uh also you would you
would um be providing because in part
that uh RSA RSA
33a uh 5A Roman 3 we're we're having the
municipality um if they are doing this
then they would be public uh providing
one cost-free method of accessing the
website now if there needs to be help
using the
website um I believe that should be
directed to
the um the archist not the municipality
as far as because the municip the
archivist is is is experts on the
website since they created it their it
they they would be able to help the um
someone use it if if there was an issue
with that thank you followup go ahead uh
would there be funding available for the
additional labor at the archists
office thank you for the question that
there is funding in this bill for a
person that that is essentially
overseeing that
um the website and and
uh all
also doing let's see
on line um 9 through
um it they're going to be helping local
government uh
uh Municipal records uh advise the
municipal records boards concerning
local government records policies and
procedures State services and financial
reporting advise local officials and and
and regulations pertaining to local
government so they're going to be
helping in more than just the website
they're going to be helping facilitate
uh you know the municipalities to upload
it correctly lots of other things but I
think that that the state archist would
probably be the the person to uh more
directly answer it because the state
archist said that this is the person
that she needs to be able to to fulfill
the requirements of this bill so that's
that's what I proposed so thank you for
the
question
lales thank you for taking my
question I um applaud your attempt here
to to make it uh uh easier for people to
respond to these requests but I'm just
wondering the there is a city and I
don't know if anybody here represents
that city that has over the last few
years been
inundated with right to know
requests
if that city was able to say here you go
here's all our records I'm sure they
would love to do that but would this law
absolve the city of that responsibility
and I think from the nods I I
I I see that some of my colleagues
acknowledge that it's a big deal
responding to right to no
requests and uh I can't
imagine uh the city in question not
saying here you go State archist here's
thank you for the comment statement
statement well the the question is would
this law okay yes say to that City well
it's up to the archist the city doesn't
have any responsibility repres Kelly I
think you can answer that with a yes or
no for us yes if they if they upload it
to the website on on line uh 1 two and
three of page two they would be absolved
of fulfilling that right to no request
that is the win-win win that I'm talking
about thank you representative
priest thank you Mr chairman for uh
taking my question and thank you for
being here absolutely what assurances
can you give the municipalities if they
take your suggestion and upload all
their information onto your
website and that website is hacked and
that information is
gone and they no longer have a hard copy
of those records thank you for for the
question uh the municipality is no
longer on the hook for those records as
far as the fulfilling those right to no
requests however the state archivist is
her whole job is to Archive stuff so I
think she and her her expertise will be
able to you know uh fulfill the
requirements of of the law as far as uh
you know off offline backups and stuff
like that that's it's you know well
within the scope of her duties
representative Elward thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for taking my question thank you so I'm
trying to
Envision um having to obtain records
pertaining to subject matter that might
run across three different boards the
select board the planning board the
zba and not sure what
records contain the answers that I'm I'm
looking for are you saying that the
technology uh implemented by the
archist will be able to search through
all the documentation to identify the
records that I I need thank you for uh
the question um there's technology um
such as OCR which is optical character
recognition which which goes through um
documents to uh essentially uh make them
searchable so that you could put in a
keyword and it will pull up all the all
the things with the keyword um this is
you know a technical as far uh
implementation of the of the website
that um that uh the archist is kind of
already scoped out the website that uh I
think she in hopes to use in in
fulfilling this so she may be able to
talk more about how that um the
capabilities of the website that she has
in mind thank you
absolutely representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question it's a simple
yes yes or no
answer with regards to the publicly
accessible website will this website be
ADA Compliant
yes further
questions seeing none I have one
representative yella um represent Elward
kind of started down the path the
question I have and that is would a m
municipality be obligated should they
may elect to may be
stored would all the Departments all the
boards be required is in other words is
it an all or none type of decision by
the municipality in other words the
planning board decides no we're not
going to do this the finance department
says yeah we're going to do this and
different departments within the same
municipality uh elect to or elect not to
is it again is it going to be an all or
nothing for the
municipality thank you for the question
I'm not 100% sure about the what you
mean by All or Nothing um but
the the as as far as their
um
the the absolving of the responsibility
under 91a that's on a record by record
basis so if you uploaded three records
now you absolve yourself of the
91a uh responsibility for three records
if you upload 100,000 you've absolved
yourself for 100,000 you only absolved
yourself for the records that you've
uploaded so if a municipality decided
that they wanted to put all the records
up then they could be absolved of all of
it but if they in any any percentage
thereof I
guess follow up for myself I guess to
clarify it a little a little
more if there's an issue that somebody
has a 91a request and it permeates more
than a single committee a single board
or something like that and some of the
data is stored at the state level and
the rest is stored down
here isn't that going to make a 91 91a
request on a specific issue a little bit
everybody thank you for for the
the let's say if you you had a topic of
you know everything that had to do with
this
appropriation and that Span in multiple
things but you've only uploaded the
documents for like the select board but
the appropriation like where they
actually approved the appropriation but
the planning board didn't upload the
documents so the town manager um would
provide the documents as far as the
appropriation for the planning board and
then provide the website for the
additional documents and so
the each each record um would be handled
individually as far as
um the the town manager would know like
okay we've record we've uploaded you
know everything from the select board or
whatever so it would I'm not sure that
it would be any more work it would be
less work that's not what I'm asking
okay so I'll do a second followup okay
the issue is if I decide I want a 91a
request on something that's G on in the
town of barington and that issue that
I'm looking into uh spans several
committees or different boards or
whatever and the local government
records manager has elected to only put
one or two of those committees up at the
at The Archives and has decided they're
going to keep the others
here the individual requesting the 91 a
then is not going to know do I have to
go to the state archive do I have to go
to the town do I have to go to both what
am I doing is that a correct
assumption thank you for the question um
yes they could just request if if they
believe all the documents are not on the
website they could just request the
document the request just like they
would normally from a municipality and
the municipality would then fulfill the
requests for the documents that are not
up on the site and provide them the
website address for the documents that
are up on the website
so if you just make the request they you
would be provided with the
information and who who is the
individual requesting the 91a going to
make the request to the
town local
government man or the one at The
Archives because once thanks thank you
for the question there isn't a Lo local
records manager at the local
municipality that's not what this bill
envisions the local records manager is
an employee of the state
archivist and they help both the
municipality and people you trying to
use that website um but the the requests
for 91a would still go to the same place
that they do now usually the P person is
a manager or town clerk or something
like that that you could give the
request to and they they would respond
with either let's say a business card
with the phone or the website address or
they would be giving you a stack of
paper and a website or just a stack of
paper thank you I'll thank you well I'll
ask question elsewhere yes
representative kale thank you Mr to
thank you for taking my question do we
have an idea of how many 91a requests
are done throughout all municipalities
is there is there a
number thank you for the question there
is no requirement anywhere that that
such a list be kept um
however if you
if let's say for for my town I've went
and scanned all of their documents so is
that just one request or is that a
request for every single document since
1970 so I don't it's to even gauge what
that what that would mean quick followup
followup just wondering if only I'm
imagining hundreds of thousands of 91a
requests across the whole state yeah I'm
imagining that is is one person at the
state archive going to be able to handle
that thank you for the question
hopefully
most most of the requests as far as um
you know request to see a document
that's on the website is not actually
going to require any work by the records
manager it would just be a search of the
database and the database would return
the result without any actual labor by
that that records manager the only only
issue would be if someone like was
having trouble with it and they needed
help with the website or something like
that as far as actual
labor thank you for the
question okay thank you representative y
Kell seeing no more questions I will
call Ashley Miller and Aaron Hennessy
office good afternoon everyone I'm Aaron
Hennessy I'm the deputy secretary of
state and with me today is Ashley Miller
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee um I support House Bill 1708
as the Director of archives and Records
management for the state our division is
often sought out by m municipalities for
answers to their records related
questions as you know New Hampshire has
homed over 200 municipalities each with
their own challenges a local government
records manager plays a crucial role in
ensuring efficient recordkeeping this
role will allow us to reach every every
municipality to promote and Implement
systematic organization preserve the
historical records that they do have and
train them on digitization and metadata
standards this bill does not create any
new positions within the Secretary of
State's office but does fund a currently
unfunded
one with the funding of this position we
can better serve all of our
municipalities by providing Outreach
training best best practices and a
convenient repository where their
records can both be preserved and
accessible to the public archives are
arsenals of accountability we strive to
preserve the historical record to
promote government
transparency increased access to records
for the public allows citizens to
monitor government activities and
exercise their rights as informed
participants in the Democratic process
thank you to the committee for the
opportunity to speak and I'm happy to
take any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee representative Maj uh
majori thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for being here and taking my
question training can you do you have
any idea in your head what the training
might involve based on maybe the history
of queries that have come to you yes so
thank you for your question um so
training would involve heavily um
digitization training and training on
metadata so
municipalities would upload their own
documents the local government records
manager would train them on how to do so
and Implement metadata standards for
them so that the items uploaded are
searchable you're welcome thank you
representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so in your
testimony you stated that this bill
would not create a new position however
it would fund an unfunded position could
you clarify that unfunded
position thank you for the question
representative the uh unfunded position
currently is a position that has already
been created so it's it might be more of
a technical financial situation we're in
but it doesn't create a new position it
just funds one that has previously been
currently does that answer your
question well follow up thank you Mr
chairman so just to be clear this
unfunded position like you said is a
separate new position and it's not the
the the ladies next to you the director
of archives I'm sorry I missed your name
it's not that position you're referring
to there would be two positions no hers
so the state archist is is a position is
a current position um this position the
local records manager position would be
a position within archives and Records
management which is a division within
the Secretary of State's
Department represent Gallagher so my
question was actually kind of along the
same lines about the um position in
question uh so if this position exists
but is currently
unfunded um does that mean is there
anyone currently filling it is there are
are it's current dut duties being
performed at all or is that um lapsed
due to the lack of funding thank you for
the question no there is no current
human in that position and we do not
currently fulfill those duties to the
municipalities represent Brown I saw
your hand yes um thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question I
guess uh one of the questions concerns
moving forward is is there a particular
format that all these records are going
to be requ ired to being or is a system
going to be able to adapt to whatever
these M municipalities or cities um
currently
use thank you for the question um with
the database that I'm currently looking
at um I can tell you it's preserva more
than half of the states actually use it
um and we can select a format where we
require or anything uploaded can be
transferred to the format we required so
very little lift on the side of the
municipality Representative howand no
sorry actually I just have a question
because so besides the $150,000 position
everything else that we need the
software the storage everything that
already exists in budget we're just you
know we can already pull it off if we
have the $150,000 person thank you for
your question so the 150,000 covers both
the position and the database we don't
currently have the
database representative Elwood thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question um will the municipalities need
like a high-speed scanner or additional
equipment I mean I have the desk printer
type scanner situation but um does this
impose a
mandate thank you for your question a
basic scanner is fine anything that can
scan up to 400 to 600 DPI which which is
you any further
questions I have one um okay so here's
the
scenario the town of barington decides
to send their planning board and Zoning
Board documents up to the
the building inspector or somebody
else's records up so the records now are
in two places as a
91a individual who wants a
91a uh request walk me through who I'm
going to contact for that do
good thank you for your question so just
to clarify anyone who has a 91 a request
for a municipality is going to reach out
to that municipality directly the
municipal government um is doing the
uploading of those documents they know
exactly what's on the website and what
they still have or are wanting to do and
they are the ones providing the link to
the documents on their website so they
are reaching out to the
municipality so it's my understanding
who the individual contacts is not going
to change under there
correct okay um final question and the
reason I ask that it it
talks I kind of inferred from the
language on
26 line 26 where it says the municipal
municipality provides the public at
least one cost-free method of accessing
the website so that's only for somebody
who just wants to access it it's not
they're not going to be required to use
that access to search and do their own
91a
request thank you um but the
municipality could still provide the
link to the documents in
question for the 91a
request understood thank you
representative
El thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so I'm envisioning um
completing the minutes of a select board
meeting
electronically where does that document
go from
there thank you for your question so
from there if you were the one to do the
uploading you would upload it directly
to the
database um with some metadata and it
ahead oh so on the town website would
there be a link that says search direct
records or public record request or
something like that and and wouldn't
have to bother the the municipality
staff thank you for your question
certainly that's up to the town but they
absolutely could okay thank
you representative
fre thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question and thank you for being here
what security uh what
um the word I want is um how can you
give us the
assurances that the information that we
digitize and we sent to you will be
secured and the website will not crash
and you won't lose the information
because of the volume of information
thank you thank you for your question um
so the database I'm currently looking at
again more than half of these states use
it um immediately upon ingestion a
preservation copy is made of documents
that are uploaded um and it's passes
several cyber security tests I'd be
happy to email that information if to
like representative
kill just to follow up on what you just
said so you receive the data to the
database and are did you just say you
print off a copy for the archives too
okay what was that word you just said
immediately upon ingestion to the
database a preservation copy is made
within the database an electronic Copy
Quick followup so that would be the same
database yes the the database we're
discussing triple followup oh gosh no uh
we're gonna go over here you can it's
saved elsewhere only the chairman gets
triple follow-ups representative frct
yes thank you for taking my question
um I can foresee that the process of
uploading ongoing current documents
would be a fairly
insubstantial amount of staff burden on
the individual
municipalities um if a town were to want
to upload documents from
1984 onwards
time thank you for your question I
believe that's up to the municipality to
to answer not to me and not to answer
for you but that question I think has
been asked before and the answer is this
is enabling legislation it's not
mandatory so the town has the choice of
whether they wish to do that or not and
if they choose to do that I would say
the cost would be born by the town
chairman
hello I was wondering under 33a record
retention schedule they have all the
different amounts of time is there any
reason why records cannot be kept in
perpetuity through this
system thank you for your question uh no
there's not I mean there are certain
records historical records for example
you seeing no further questions thank
you for your
testimony okay we have one more on one
more pink card on 1708 Margaret Burns
and
HMA
good afternoon I'm Margaret burns with
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
I will try to be brief on this bill um
nhma supports this bill and we want to
note that we were very pleased to work
with the prime sponsor over the summer
to try to come up with language that
worked on what he was trying to
accomplish with this piece of
legislation as we see it this bill is a
local option it does not mandate
municipalities to do or not to do
anything but instead creates a place on
the state archive website uh for them to
upload records if that is convenient and
if they wish to participate in that kind
of program the way I see the bill as
well is that it could potentially cut
down both on right to no law request
coming directly to municipalities as
well so the burden on municipalities
themselves while it could also take away
some burden on individuals needing to
make requests as in if records are
available in one central location
citizens have the ability to go on there
search for information that they're
looking for and if they're not able to
find it they of course can always make
right to no law request to the
municipality or in the reverse if a
citizen makes a right to no law request
to the municipality and they're looking
for minutes that span over 20 years on a
particular subject if the municipality
has opted to upload all of their minutes
going back to X date they're able to
point the citizen to that searchable
database and tell them that those
records are available there as maybe
other records from the municipality
having heard the questions and comments
of this committee it may be prudent that
there are language or other recommended
changes that would assist this
legislation in better effectuating its
purpose and of course I'm happy to take
any questions thank you very much
representative Elward thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so so I'm thinking of a town
that is
and would it not be a decision the
people make
versus government officials whether or
not
happen I'm in a in a way it is the
decision of the voters voters will um
elect in individuals and select board
members and those select board members
have the ability to effectuate policy
and that policy could include opting in
to putting their records onto the state
archives I don't see that this gives any
Avenue to an intentionally obdurate
municipality to Sherk its
responsibilities under the right to no
law instead instead what it's doing is
expanding a platform where records can
be searched which would not otherwise be
available so the obligation to respond
to right to no law
requests is not affected by the
proposed follow up Mr chairman
representative Elward go ahead could it
be put so could it could a um citizen
petition
uh
to instruct the the town to opt into
this um
program if this legislation passed
certainly citizens can petition anything
they wish um to go onto the warrant
article some articles uh petitioned by
citizens are advisory as in they are a
statement to their select board that
they wish to see a certain policy
implemented as opposed to mandatory
which requ requires that the action go
through in this circumstance the
proposed legislation does not have a
provision about a warrant article being
the Avenue for for making this happen so
in that case it would likely be an
advisory warrant article that citizens
could tell their governing body we would
like to do this thank you so much
representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chairman is it feir
to say that this program would really
only be effective if all towns
partici participated and in a fragmented
program where it's one town or another
would be hilly nilly sort of that that
makes the program ineffective because of
not having all the towns participate I
don't think it makes it ineffective
having records compiled in a place where
they don't currently exist having more
records for municipalities in a place
that is not currently available to
citizens would only increase
transparency and increase the amount of
records that are just generally publicly
available and certainly there are
municipalities who don't have the
internal capacity to do the scanning and
other functions necessary to get their
records back to the start of time um
into the state archives so we would not
want to see municipalities burdened with
a mandate to do something they don't
have internal capacity to do at this
time thanks than you M follow up Mr
chairman I don't think I don't think I
asked the question correctly probably I
the point I'm trying to make is if you
have all the communities participating
in a program like this it's really great
and effective but if you have a
fragmented program I wonder if it's
worth the effort so I don't think I got
that across so thank you anyway for your
answer I apologize for misunder
further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony uh have no more pink cards
there were nobody who signed in on the
blue sheet yay or nay so with that we'll
go ahead and close the hearing on HB
1708 now representative Grassley I see
you in the back of the room I know
you're here for
your uh HB 1641 uh hold
on
sorry we are extremely far behind what
we're going to do representative is we
will hear your bill at 1:00 on the hour
for the committee members you that'll
give us 15 minutes to do whatever you
would like get a snack eat drink use the
facilities if you elect to have a longer
lunch that's up to you but we will start
o'clock
for
okay folks one minute warning and then
going
okay we are going to get started and
open up the hearing on HB
1641 relating to no HB
1544 relative to indemic indemnification
from municipalities adopting policies to
address homelessness I see the prime
sponsor representative grassy is here
representative grassy you have the floor
thank you my name is uh Chuck grassy I'm
state representative from Rochester
award four um litigation it's probably a
word that sends shivers down the backs
of most
Selectmen councilmen or Alderman here in
the state of New Hampshire that one word
litigation um I've been working with a
group in straford County dealing with
homeless it's a housing first group and
we've been looking at the issue of how
to deal with our unhoused I noticed
there was a report recently at the state
there was some numbers that were thrown
around that there are about 1,600 people
that are unhoused in the state of New
Hampshire we have better indications
those people who we would look at as
being unhoused those people who are
living in cars people who are couch
surfing or people who are living in
tents in the woods of about a thousand
people just in straford County alone so
we're thinking that maybe their numbers
at the state are are missing a lot of
people people that do not know where
they're going to sleep tomorrow night uh
or tonight even in some cases uh and and
so what we looked at with this in this
group that in straford County there's a
number of people that has caps that has
welfare directors the the uh community
action groups uh housing specialist uh
from the city of Dober is there as well
so we have both you know we have
Municipal groups we have have church
groups we have a number of different
Outreach people from the hospitals who
we working together to try to find a
solution and we broke up into
subcommittees and one of the things that
we one of the first questions I asked
when I got into our subcommittee which
was the policy subcommittee was what are
the obstacles that we have to solving
the problems why are not municipalities
is doing more and the immediate word
that came up was
litigation most communities when you're
sitting there and talking about doing
something for the homeless such as if
you've got a situation where you've got
to clear out a a tent city uh because
it's being disruptive it's in somebody's
backyard in in Rochester it's either in
the Hansen Pines which are which is our
City forest basically or behind wendes
they just tend to move back and forth
because it's just across the street uh
but I've had numerous calls from
individuals saying I've got a group of
people living in my backyard uh they're
just far enough into the woods where I
can't see them every day but they're
there and there's trash all over the
place and why doesn't the city do
anything about it well you know some
places have looked at the city owns some
land where we can provide a place for
people to stay uh that if you want to
live in if you have to live in a tent go
to this place we can provide limited
security but we can't provide a lot the
one thing that most as a city councilman
which I was a city council Rochester for
30 years as a city councilman if I was
to look at my city manager and say why
can't we do this we have some city land
that we could put these people on it has
relative safety uh you know we we don't
have to provide 247 security to this
place but people you know just give them
a place where they can live with they're
not going to be on somebody else's land
they're not going to be in a place it's
going to be they're not going to be on
the streets my city manager would
probably call primex who is our
insurance provider and he would come
back to me and he would say
litigation I don't want to be in a situ
and as a city councilman I would have
that shiver go up my back and I would
say yeah City doesn't want to get
involved with if there's a possibility
that we could get sued and we could be
in court for an extended period of time
I've worked with a number of groups in
the state to talk about this on how can
we solve this problem of litigation and
where's the balance where you provide
protection for a community who wants to
do something for the homeless um and but
you provide housing for the homeless
possibly you provide opportunities for
the homeless
um you know many cities and towns don't
have the ability the uh the resources to
put up a shelter with security with
locked doors sometimes it may be reusing
an old building that may be available or
having a place where people can come and
park their cars if they're living in
their cars as a temporary solution until
we can find more opportunities for them
and uh working with uh insurance
providers working with the
municipalities and working with the
Human Services groups and you've got
letters from the wealth administrators
here and the chairman the president of
their Welfare Association is here to
speak and also from rights and democracy
who is an Outreach group working with
homeless the homeless community and
throughout the state um we looked at a
balance what's a good tradeoff here that
if I was to provide
immunity from litigation to local
communities or local
governments would this give them the
opportunity to say yes I will do more to
provide opportunities for housing or for
the homeless I will provide a reasonably
safe place for them to park their cars
if they're living in cars until I can
find something better for them um and
and most every group said if it'll if
it'll make a difference let's do it and
so I submitted the legislation and and
working with with other groups and the
municipal Association rights and
democracy a few others to say that you
know this is an opportunity that we want
to be able to provide so that
communities can't say litigation is an
obstacle to providing opportunities for
homeless for housing um you know this is
a very basic level we're not you know
and and it's to get communities to do
more to provide that protection for them
questions rep excuse me representative
yella thank you thank you for taking the
question you keep on mentioning uh
reasonably safe um how do you define
that and H how is that
only uh in the bill as far as it's it's
not in the bill and when I when I say
that is right now you've got people
parking at parking rides and they're
there on their own we don't know where
they are we have no um you know there's
no agreement that they can park there 24
hours a day or multiple days uh one day
a couple of terms ago I was driving into
conquer and I was waiting for somebody
who was car pooling with me and I pulled
into the park and ride in Rochester on
Route 202 and and I was waiting for
another rep to show up and there was
this car parked in front of us in front
of me uh and and I all of a sudden it
was about time for school to start and I
it was one head pops up then a second
head pops up one in the back seat one in
the front seat I see a guy get out of
the car run into the woods another guy
get out of the car get his backpack and
you can see he's putting his textbooks
in his
backpack and then when the guy comes in
from the W the other guy goes into the
woods guy sitting there with a bottle of
water and a toothbrush brushing his
teeth changing his shirt and this was in
the middle of winter
they were living in a car and there were
two students who were going to I'm
assuming Spalding High School because
they were that age but they were living
in a car I drove by there another day
after that and that car was there the
next day and the next day that car was
there on their own I mean we can't keep
track of them we can't do anything at
all about them if we were able to
provide let's say the city may have a
parking lot um affiliated with a a
building that we own we may own isn't
used we can say Park here um and then we
can may be able to provide where we know
that the Cruisers will go by there to a
three times a night just to make sure
that there's some reasonable safety it's
not defined in the bill but it's the
thing is is that if the city isn't
protected from any liability here if
they allow people to park on their lot
and something happens they will be sued
if they're right now these people are
parking in parking rides they're parking
on you know in back of people barns um
and there is no protection for these
people whatsoever there is no security
for these people if something happens we
don't many times we won't even know
about it until we find the the body or
the person turns up at the hospital um
the thing is that right now there is no
security these people people who are
living in the woods have no security if
we could have a city city-owned land
that we could put something on and say
you can stay here at least we know where
they are at least we're able to keep
track of the situation we're able to
keep it cleaner um but litigation is the
one thing that doesn't allow us to do
that right now or it doesn't encourage
us to do
that representative Holland thank you
for taking my question um so my my
question really resolves around the uh
uh not so much like the safety but it
was like uh septic water uh trash you
were talking about public health
standards that are required so I mean
I'm assuming in Rochester suddenly you
have a a Cera outbreak because you've
had like this encampment without septic
um what is the m municipality absolved
of their Public Health responsibilities
well first of all uh uh do you know of
any encampments out on the woods right
now which aren't basically sanctioned by
any community that have septic and water
or any sanitary Provisions whatsoever
one of the things we may be able to do
if the community has granted this uh
they may be able to put up uh porta
potties which currently do not exist in
most of these encampments as I said when
I watch those two young men get out of
that car one of them went into the woods
I'm sure he wasn't doing his homework uh
and then the next person went into the
woods and they were basically doing this
on State Property because it was a state
parking ride or they were going on to
the next person's property uh the land
owner next to them and doing something
there right now this this trash is
there's a Home Depot in the city of
Rochester and they have a fence along
their property but they own property
outside that along a public road and
every year when the electric company
goes and clears out the brush you see
where the encampment was and we have to
go in and clean or volunteer groups go
in and clean that up if we move to a
community where we may be able to
provide a dumpster uh we may be able to
provide porta potties right now these
people have
nothing
representative Mr chair if you don't
mind I have two separate lines of
questioning you may ask the first one
and then request a
followup thank you for taking my
question so you told us the story about
those Folks at the park and ride What
stopped you from helping them
individually this there's nothing I can
do I mean I reported it that I saw what
looked like students at the park and
ride um but the city has no
responsibilities there I mean the thing
is is how much can we do for these
people if you go up and you bother them
they may just drive off and go to
another Park and Ride I was I was asking
what you stopped you individually from
helping them at the time I was P waiting
for somebody to head to conquer it I
wasn't there was nothing I could do for
them I don't have the I don't have the
wherewithal sir I live in a very small
home I have taken in people when I had a
larger home I have taken in people for
the nights that I've from families that
I knew but uh you know I'm unable to do
that and that's where I think the city
could help follow up representative kill
and follow up on another line of
questioning are you familiar with what's
going on with portapotty and people um
taking the toilet paper and cleaning off
their needles in the in the in the porta
potties um I understand that that is a
concern sir that's something that you
know it's up to the individual
communities to take a go with they're
going to provide as opportunities to
these people uh the thing is I
understand that is homeless people some
of them are on drugs yes and they have
needles do we just let them live in the
woods or live on other people's property
you know we need to take some
responsibility and this will help us
take that
responsibility representative
Gallagher um so uh I kind of discussed
this with you previously but just to get
it on record for the um Committee
hearing um so in this committee uh we
generally prefer um enabling
legislation over mandates so I was
wondering if you could talk about
whether you see this more as enabling or
as a
mandate sure I I mean this is something
that it's it's it's not mandating any
Community to do anything what it says if
they decide to do something they will be
held harmless and also that if a
community also wants if somebody's let's
say hurt the community could actually
negotiate with some of those people if
there was you know in any way possible
the committee was responsible for that
uh such as um if they were in a
community parking lot and we didn't get
out there in sand right after the storm
and somebody slipped and fell um the
community could provide assistance for
that person if they wanted to uh it
doesn't deny them that ability uh what
it does say though that you know what
you look at right now these people have
no protection none whatsoever zero if
they're going to be putting into a city
facility or you know a town facility
some areas I think it we're able to
provide a safer of them without any
responsibilities for the government to
say that you know if you want to slip
and fall you can't sue me um or if you
get attacked you can't sue me uh because
if you do we're not going to provide
that opportunity we will you will have
zero opportunities uh cities and towns
IP alties government of agencies will
shy away from doing anything more than
the bare minimum I mean right now courts
are ordering municipalities to do this
and they're doing it at quite a bit of
risk um and and the thing is so that's
why you see a lot of communities just
refuse to do anything this will
eliminate that road block for them to do
things they can say now if we want to do
something and we're not going to provide
security or we're not going to provide
Wastewater or sanitary services you know
you can't sue us um you know surely we
can we can regulate the number of people
that are in a certain area and you know
when there were 20 people there you need
to go to another facility and we just
take every we're looking at in the in in
the straford County area that we have
close to a thousand people right now
that who are on hun house or couch
surfing um you know this will give an
opportunity for for place people to do
more Ian there's an old building that
needs basic Renovations but to really
bring it up to code it's going to cost
you know a million dollars we may be
able to do this so so I I assume your
answer was yes it is enabling legisl
yeah thank you representative yella
thank you thank you for taking another
question
um it seems like the premise of your
bill is that um is to essentially in
encourage people to not use Park and
rides or other
facilities however nothing in this bill
would prevent them from doing that even
if such a place um as you suggest
was was put in their municipality is
that correct well the the one thing is
we have a park in downtown Rochester in
the city of Rochester that you're not
supposed to be there overnight there are
people there overnight the police could
now take and say you know look you can't
be here but you can be there gives us an
opportunity to say people who are living
who are camping out on sidewalks the
police can move them now we have an
opportunity for them to go someplace
else right now most times the courts
have said that if you move them you have
to provide someplace else for them to go
and this provides them someplace else to
may
if when someone
is somewhere that they're not supposed
to be kind of the risk and the liability
they're taking on that risk themselves
when you put someone in a particular
place that is unsafe or whatever
I don't understand why you think that
that that you say like here I'm going to
put I want you to go to this place that
we know is unsafe because it doesn't
have the necessary sanitary conditions
and stuff like that why is why is that
something that you see as um something
that that they should be able to throw
their hands up as far as liability and
say yeah I put you in this place on my
on purpose but it was dangerous and you
got harmed well right right now they're
living on private IND individuals or
private businesses properties those
businesses or individuals don't really
want them there uh they cause problems
for those businesses and those
individuals what we're doing is we're
offering a location that the city owns
that you know basically they're not
getting any more than what they were
getting getting before it's just a place
where we allow them to go represent that
may seem harsh but that's a reality
representative PRI uh thank you Mr
chairman for taking my question and
thank you for being here um my
understanding is that this bill if an
acted would protect the municipalities
who are offering a lot of of their land
to the homeless for a temporary shelter
it would not give them the
indentification from an adjacent
property owner who is suing the city for
devouring their property uh value is
that correct uh yeah that that could be
correct uh but right now those homeless
people could be living in their
backyards
um you know so it's it's you know
homeless situations that are going on
right now devaluate individuals
properties all over the place and I
wouldn't think that the city would would
do something where they would put them
right in the middle of a residential
neighborhood but you know that may occur
most of the land that we have is like
Farmer Industrial or business sites that
we have that have been demolished or a
building that may still be there that we
may be able to offer without doing a lot
of uh safety code violations you know
getting it up to code but you provide
them a warm and dry place for the night
representative
Elwood representative Elwood withdraws
PR thank you Mr chairman Mr uh
representative grassy do you have any
stats on how many homeless
individuals have sued a municipality for
personal injury or other damages and if
any how many of those suits have been
successful well I I I do not I know that
we get there are regular occurrences
where people slip on sidewalks where we
get sued um and I don't think that's the
point it doesn't really yeah I I don't
have that information on how many
homeless people may have sued uh but the
thing is is that I I don't think that's
the point that we're looking at here
we're providing opportunities for
municip for municipalities to provide
opportunities for these people to as
places to stay follow uh follow up go
ahead um are are we looking at a problem
that doesn't exist and trying to create
a solution to a different
problem no sir at all we're looking at a
problem that exists and we're providing
a solution to that problem
representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman um thanks for taking my
question so can you define for me um
clearly what duty of care is and how
this um bill is going to um other than
other than uh keeping municipalities
from lawsuits um how this addresses is
the the duty of care
issue I I don't know if I can answer
that question for you you you know
someone from the municipal Association
may be able to answer that better for
you as far as duty of care um all I I I
know that what I'm proposing here is to
provide them nothing more than they
already have just in a better
location representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh my
understanding of the responsibility of
municipalities as far as well welfare
goes and and this kind of problem would
be you know something will be solved
um how would this work with that um
because what I understand is that if
somebody say comes to exiter
from
NASA um do we have to
if we usually refer them back to naswa
because that's you know where the quot
the care should come from um
but if their incident for an example
we're having a problem countywide uh
with our
uh well Sheriff's Department um
Corrections Department
they what are we supposed to do with
people from other communities I guess
from what I understand and and and
working in my task force that I work on
is and we have the head of the State
Welfare Association administrative
Association here he would be certainly
be able to give you much more
information on that but there was a bill
passed recently which we keep track of
where these people are coming from when
they come in and ask for services and
and the thing is is that this will not
end the responsibility of communities to
help the people that come in and seek
help right so it's what we're we're
talking about here is many of these
people don't seek help I understand
thank you yeah I was gonna say that
that as I've tried to have us do uh on
the committee please ask questions that
are relevant to the bill itself
uh I I know it's kind of anciliary it's
on the edge there but try to keep the
questions you know on the bill itself
Sol representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so my
question is is if this bill were to be
signed into law is it possible that an
authority or a body in charge of a
public property say for example a school
is it possible that that Authority might
say we have a need
go to remote learning and to use that
school
facility um to to to you know solve an
immediate problem I wouldn't think that
would occur and my wife served on school
board for a long time in Rochester I
couldn't see that happening at all I
sense a followup representative po thank
you I understand that you said you don't
think it would occur in in your city
no representative
Gallagher uh so this is kind of a
follow-up to representative fr's
question um he was asking about if you
had statistics about
um about lawsuits that have been filed
um my question is would you agree that
um the problem this bill's trying to
solve isn't so much
existing lawsuits as it is the chilling
effect that the threat of lawsuits might
have
awesome
okay U and kind of a followup to
representative power's question I'm
going to just read right here all public
property may be used for leisure time
activities and temporary shelter Andor
Aid of the homeless provided that prior
approval was for its use was granted by
the appropriate Authority in charge of
that property would you believe that in
other states enabling legislation is
allowing them to force students
into going to school from home while
their school is being used to shelter
people I wouldn't think any school board
in their right mind would do that it's
it's already happening it's already
happening yeah I couldn't see that
happening in New
Hampshire further questions
representative stavis thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question do
you have any uh research or analysis on
how insurers might respond to this uh in
terms of raising the rates on
municipalities and what the impact would
be on taxpayers if that were to happen
yes i' I I had a good long conversation
with primex um and and their General
Counsel on this but uh just one thing
that I want to just answer the from the
previous question is that that can
already occur they can already use
schools if if a school department wanted
to use that that this bill makes no
difference um because they would just
take on the liability that's all uh yes
as far as the cost right now if it if
things happened if someone was hurt uh
they could sue a city or municipality or
government entity uh municipalities
basically up to $325,000 per currence
and or per individual and 1 million per
occurrence but it's sometimes it's a
litigation in that whole situation that
cities have the Deep Pockets cities and
towns have the Deep Pockets so they're
going to go after those people and the
thing is is that that would cause your
up right now if we leave them in the
woods they not our
responsibility further comments or uh
questions I mean seeing N I have a
couple um thank you for your testimony
um throughout the bill there's a few
words that I'd like to get your comments
on or actually your definition on the
first one is temporary what what is the
Bill's intent of the word temporary well
it's a situation where until the
community can provide more secure
housing or more secure locations for
them we may move them to a temporary
area such as if we were to do something
in Rochester we have a piece of land
near the center of city was farmer uh
industrial site that we could move them
temporarily there until we could provide
more secure housing for them and I think
that's the intent of every welfare
department is to find more secure
housing for these people uh right now
they're in the woods sometimes we don't
even know they're there um when we can
get them into a location we be able to
work with them to get them into better
housing and following up would would
there be an upper limit to the term
temporary I I think that would be with
the ability of the community to be able
to provide an opportunity for them I
mean sometimes
a community starting from nothing um
you're you're talking about a very
highly transient population as well most
of these people don't move into an
encampment and stay there forever um
they move around a lot um what we're
trying to do is just make it so that
they're not uh infringing upon other
people's rights uh people's backyards
sidewalk in front of a store uh move
them from those locations uh two
locations where we have a better better
ability to manage the
situations the second definition I'm
looking for is
uh who the term homeless who would
actually qualify under that that term I
don't think there's if if someone is
unhoused I don't I think there could be
anybody that is unhoused um you know
that we would provide an opportunities
for them most of the time what you're
going to see is people already living in
the woods we're just going to move them
to a maybe a better location uh somebody
who's living in a parking ride we're
just going to move them to a better
location um individuals who are cou
surfing there not much you can do about
them they're probably going to continue
to cou Surf but they could be in a tent
time my followup to that was in kind of
going down the road that representative
kahill was referring to although
obliquely um currently for example in
New Hampshire we have
approaching
14,000 illegal living in our state
illegal aliens
um do you
see uh illegal aliens being eligible
under your homeless def definition or is
it going to be citizens or uh residents
of the town of Rochester or how usually
if we're asking people in a tent or
under a tarp in the middle of the woods
to move to another location we don't
usually ask where they're from um we
have to provide opportunities for
everyone and I don't think that's
something that we're going to you know I
need to see an D before you can go here
because if we don't they're just going
to stay where they are or they're going
to move to another location which is
going to infringe on somebody else's
rights um you know we're trying to make
it so that municipalities as it was said
right under current law there's a
chilling effect on the communities
communities doing
anything we'd like the communities to do
more I'm not asking questions about drug
use I'm not asking questions about where
they're from if they're from Maine um
you know if they're living in the woods
in Rochester we're going to find a place
for them that's better than where they
are if they're back at Wendy's or they
in somebody's backyard you go out one
day and when the leaves drop and all of
a sudden you see a bunch of trash and
Tents in your backyard what do you do
first thing you do is call the police
police ask them to move they move to
your neighbor's
backyard okay thank you any further
questions representative go um GTH yeah
thank you Mr chairman for bringing a
question to mind whatever happened to
the welfare system where people coming
into the town they say Here I Am My I
got a a son in my car and I have no
place to live find me a place to live
what's ever whatever happened to that
system that is still that is still
functioning and you'll have the welfare
director from the city of Rochester
who's chairman of the State Association
who will be here to to address that for
you uh it's still occurring we are
putting people up in hotels and motels
uh and finding any housing we can but
the system is stretched to its limits I
mean there are only so many hotel rooms
out there I know one Motel facility in
Rochester that is entirely uh welfare
housing follow up Mr chairman what's the
difference between the homeless and
somebody that comes into a
community uh with a family and has no
place to live in other words is it am I
correct in saying that if a
welfare candidate comes into a community
you can say we don't have any place
tough
luck and then they'll live in their
they'll they'll find a place behind a
building in town that nobody seems to
see and they'll sleep in their car for
the night or maybe a week um you know
yeah that that may happens so we'll put
them on a list uh but again the welfare
director will be able to give you a
better response to that we try to help
as many people as we can and we do as
much as we can sometimes if there's no
opportunity and you have to basically
tell that person well you know give me a
couple days and I'll get you a place
what am I going to do in the meantime
you know we'll see what we can do and we
may send them to a place they may show
up there and it may they may say I don't
want to be here so they stay in their
car
overnight that's not happening in the
small towns it is okay thank you Mr
chairman representative uh
yella thank you thank you for taking the
question um
could this be used as a loophole to
designate all of their public property
in the town um
um uh essentially
uh options to provide temporary shelter
and then uh and then make anyone suing
them prove that they're not homeless
before they that they don't qualify
under the definition of homeless so that
they are are then liable for the town
that's pretty far-fetched I don't see
that as possible thank you
no okay seeing no more questions thank
you very much representative grassy uh
next we'll call Representative Jody new
is you got
it um thank you Mr chair and thank you
to the committee members for giving me
your time and attention today um I think
representative grassy uh covered things
really well and it sounds like there are
people who can uh speak a little more
detail after me so I'm going to keep it
nice and short and
sweet uh I represent chesher 4 I am also
a homeless Advocate having worked uh for
close to a decade and volunteering three
times as much in a transitional family
shelter that my grandmother founded when
I was four uh I also began uh have been
actively involved in trying to support
those experiencing homelessness in my
own community of keen particularly those
who make a tent their home uh in the
woods of our little city the issue of
Housing and the extreme lack of it is
known to every single one of us I'm sure
more people are falling through the
cracks every single day I understand and
I am proud that we have made strong
efforts to expand our system of support
for the unhoused including addressing
contributing factors and likewise I
understand that these resources are
limited having worked with our city lead
leaders um Grassroots activists and
activists and folks struggling with
housing themselves I believe there's
more we can do but there are structural
barriers uh to utilizing every tool in
our toolbox this bill in essence seeks
to remove one of these barriers and give
municipalities the ability to decide
whether or not uh they want to utilize
other resources I would appreciate your
vote and support of this important bill
told you to be short and
sweet questions from the committee
seeing none thank thank you very much
for your testimony thank you next we
Marsh
okay good afternoon um my name is Todd
Marsh I am the uh welfare director for
the City of Rochester however I am here
today as president of of the New
Hampshire local welfare administrators
Association um and in support of hb1
1544 uh I am capable of being short and
sweet and uh I am confident I will do
that today um so just in brief um the
New Hampshire local welfare
administrator Association is a
professional nonprofit organization that
educates and supports our Municipal
members to Foster compliant humanitarian
and fiscally responsible assistance
practice practices when assisting
residents with RSA 165 colon 1 uh
statutorily obligated basic needs so as
stated um we do support this bill as an
association uh we believe that this
Common Ground uh initiative's passage
will increase emergency service
options um for the
unhoused uh including temporary
emergency housing options by allowing
municipalities the option to designate
public property areas to Aid Andor
provide temporary shelter for the
unhoused with minimized liability for
these efforts they're not it's not as
you can see from the from the bill
language it does not it's not void of of
liability but it does lessen it um this
initiativ this initiative is an OP is an
option or an optional one prong to a
multi-pronged approach to problem solve
multifaceted
challenges it is not the solution we
view this as a pronged and multi-pronged
approach uh this bill maintains local
control by allowing but not
mandating to designate
areas of minimized
liability to provide temporary
Sheltering services for our unhoused in
need
um I will stri some I I do not foresee
this as
necessarily uh an initiative an
initiative of mandating people need to
go here or go
there of forcing people it provides an
option um this bill maintains as I said
Lo and control uh initiatives to
increase emergency housing Services
throughout the state are often met with
concern for mandates in increased costs
I've already spoke of that this
humanitarian and costeffective expansion
of current law increases emergency
housing service options throughout our
state by decreasing concerns for
financial
liability support for the bill is a lwh
hanging fruit
solution prong I should
say while other helping initiatives are
debated for their
complexities and debate is good um I am
confident that we can agree that this
bill simply make solution finding
sense uh this bill has the support of
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
and support or at least I should say not
non- opposition from New Hampshire legal
aid uh I believe if they can
agree and and if the welfare associ
agrees that you can agree that this can
be aong and a multipronged effort um
towards solution finding options for um
questions mik I can ask a question now
just I know we got a technician in here
somewhere
you okay we got it now
yeah
you mine's working yeah it is all right
everybody is working representative yo
Kell thank you thank you for taking the
question so on line 12 and 13 it says
um
that that these uh that no one should be
held or the employee shall not be held
liable for damages in any civil action
alleging negligence related to duty of
care to a designated area to Aid or
provide temporary share um shelter for
homeless or residents so if um
the
um the town
designates their
um their Highway
Department um shed as something that
aids
in the the the um the place that they
provide this um shelter would now that
Highway shelter also be uh or Highway um
department now also because of it aiding
that other place that uh does the um
actually does provide the shelter now
that no no um no civil action for
alleged negligence shall shall occur for
that Highway uh shed
also under this law right and as you
know uh The Welfare Association was not
a writer of the bill but to answer the
question
um it it sounds based on the bill it
sounds like it would be covered under
liability um I will briefly add U that
from a weal New Hampshire from a
municipal Welfare associ Association
perspect perspective we would not we
would not look at that um as a mandated
um solution meaning if someone turns
that down we would not look at that as
well we've met our legal
obligation we would not view a shed in
that situation as um a housing solution
four representative Guth
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your your
testimony U I still have a problem maybe
because I come from a small
town is this what how does this work
into your welfare system particularly
with your responsibility to find housing
for people who are injured in no I
appreciate the question
representative
um I we view this
as meeting people where we we we view it
as meeting people where they're at um if
someone approaches any local
welfare department in the state welfare
official large city small town uh they
should be provided options uh we would
look at shelter first um there are
reasons for it uh traditional shelter uh
we would look at motel if we need to um
we I'm not sure if I answered your
question there I'm interested if I could
Mr chairman to clarify I'm looking to
see how this works into your system if
this is a respons if this is fulfill
your responsibility as a welfare agent
to Pro provide
a a a school on for two days or or
whatever the other facility recreation
facility is is available yeah we do have
a responsibility I don't see this bill
necessarily um as far as P if we're
talking public land rather a shed or um
uh an encampment uh we would not view
that as meeting our legal obligation for
providing shelter for someone in that
situation that would be more for people
who are turning re perhaps refusing
various forms of other alternative
shelters that we're offering um but off
but also meeting people where they're at
um in in at a more of a designated Place
versus where they may
be representative thank you Mr chair
sure representative uh
lales yes thank you Mr chairman um
I'm acknowledged that we have a huge
problem in this country we have a huge
problem that's affecting
every town in the state of New Hampshire
and every town in the country every town
in this country is a Border Town and we
have we're we're being faced
with large cities unable to accommodate
the homeless my question to you is
municipalities in New Hampshire
what is their
responsibility and what are the limits
of that
responsibility and what what safeguards
are in place
to keep the the
municipality from P putting people
that's going to that's going to be
impinging the rights of everybody that's
close by and that's my question because
what if the town I come from the little
town of Lichfield all right what if we
had a Greyhound bus show up
tomorrow all right and they March into
the town hall and they say I'm here I
have no clothes I have shorts on and a
t-shirt take care of me what's the town
of lichfield's responsibility in that
case
thank you thank you for your thoughts
and thank you for your questions um
under RSA
165 um it speaks of relieving and
maintaining and uh there is no with
basic needs uh so clothing would be part
of that uh in in the scenario of a bus
arriving uh it would be the
responsibility of the municipality I
suspect the municipality would reach out
to the many help the helping providers
in the area as well um and uh um but
based on current state
law uh it is Limitless in that way but
again they would be working with others
and thank you for mentioning that
unhoused Homeless exists across the
country not just New Hampshire not just
large municipalities not just the towns
um but we're operating under a very old
you know uh State
RSA uh and so in that sense it would be
we need to relieve and maintain but we
we need to offer options for people
people may refuse those options it is
not I would say about half of people
that we offer traditional shelter to
refuse once we make that offer we've met
our legal obligations so long as they're
reasonable and is not a
shed thank you further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
Chase good afternoon Representatives
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to testify today for the record my name
is Marissa Chase I'm the executive
director for the New Hampshire
Association for justice which is just a
euphemism for the trial lawyers um we
have about 400 members Statewide who uh
represent plaintiffs and primarily um in
civil access um sorry in civil lawsuits
before you continue could you please
State whether you're Pro very opposed
very poos okay thank you um while this
bill is well- intentioned and I have
great Sympathy for the aim it tries to
address I agree with representative
frats um earlier statement that this is
a solution in search of a problem um in
search of many problem s actually it's
written very broadly um this bill I uh
one of our board
members um shared some examples of what
conduct this bill would actually
immunize um former representative Israel
padra who some of you may remember um
this would immunize a shelter collapsing
on homeless people or pass or passers by
by the way this does not just um apply
to unhoused or homeless individuals this
would be anyone um uffing an injury um
giving contaminated food to homeless
people because an employee didn't check
it ahead of time accidentally giving
wrong medication to homeless people by
mistake and killing them because this
would also apply to built structures say
a city or a town um like in Manchester
used a piece of where I live used a
piece of public property um and turned
it into a homeless shelter they should
still have a duty of care um to maintain
a reasonably safe environment just like
every other
um entity does um
the any immunizing anything quote
relating to homeless Services is very
very Broad and has uh consequences that
terrify me
personally uh it creates a two-tier
system where the municipality has a duty
of reasonable care to maintain public
buildings like a town hall for everyone
and then homeless related activities are
not even afforded reasonable care so I
believe the bill unintentionally
actually discriminates against homeless
individuals um the town I will also say
that um the only immun we as an
organization Advocate against these
bills that have that seek to Grant
immunity to special classes um I've
never been in front of this committee
before because usually these bills are
in Judiciary Committee so it's nice to
see a lot of you um I would
also question the definitions that uh
like temporary any limit um homeless who
qualifies um you know I do agree that
homelessness is a Statewide problem I'm
not here to talk about the public health
policy of the State of New Hampshire in
terms of how we treat our homeless
individuals but this bill has um a lot I
believe a lot of unintended consequences
I would also Imagine the scenario that
the prime sponsor suggested if I mean
and primex would probably be the entity
to answer this not me but I would
imagine if a city or a town took an
action to kind of designate an area as a
you
know
um free space for homeless activity I
imagine that their rates would go up
their insurance rates would go up
regardless if this was in effect or not
um it's also important to note that
immunities
do not prevent lawsuits from being filed
um it just creates a you know
presumption um the only responsibility
anyone the only immunity anyone needs is
just to act as a reasonable person would
under the same or similar
circumstances um I would be afraid that
if a city or a town anywhere did not
knew that they did not have to maintain
a reasonably safe um area they would not
spend the money to do so um liability is
a protection that we should all um be
grateful for because I know nobody likes
lawyers but you don't like one until you
need one and I'm happy to try to answer
any questions thank you for your
testimony representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so I'm I'm
curious about in the bill lines 25 and
it states unless the injury or damage
was caused by the government unit unit's
intentional misconduct could could you
illustrate what that would look like
give me an example sexual
assault is an intentional misconduct
negligence simple negligence is acting
as if you are negligent that is acting
in a way that a reasonable person under
the same or similar circumstances would
not act so making a mistake but mistake
can be deadly um and I believe that
every government unit should owe a duty
of reasonable care and
safety representative
Gallagher um so you mentioned uh
being um opposed to this bill I was
wondering if um there were any
amendments that um do you think it could
be saved by Amendment or would you still
be opposed even if we did amend it thank
you for the question representative um I
I can't answer a future question without
knowing what that question is um I would
have to know what that language would
look like but this build focuses on
liability
so I I would be hardpressed to see a a
solution where we would agree with
anything that would limit an entity's
liability um that's not to say that
there aren't other solutions to try to
um end this the homelessness crisis that
our state is
facing representative
yella thank you thank you for taking the
question so we've talked a little bit
about
the designated area to provide Aid um
essentially exempting uh negligence from
the employees and then um we've also
talked a little bit about the
unintentional
conduct and you're also talked about how
you can still file the lawsuits and
essentially the the prime sponsor seem
to be
um trying to to limit lawsuits regarding
this to essentially
reduce uh the liability to the
municipality so that they could uh
perform these functions um but it seems
like there it's a lot of technicalities
inside of this language for example on
25 it says arising from or relating to
such Aid it seems like the whole lawsuit
May then Rel like be an argument about
whether or not it was relating to Aid or
not whether or not someone is liable um
if if in fact it was found to to be
exempt um or not exempt and so uh it
seems like prolonged litigation even
with the bill passage is still likely or
or possible and so it doesn't actually
achieve the the goal that it's proposed
to fix is that correct thank you
representative um I I do believe that
would be possible um I think
that trying to decipher again this bill
is pretty broad so I think if you try
to say well this was related to aid but
that wasn't related to aidid is that am
I interpreting your question correctly I
mean wouldn't the wouldn't the I will
clarify the wouldn't the the courts be
tasked with deciding like here like you
know is the this regarding the aid or is
it not regarding the aid right is is
your your Staffing functions at the
municipal Town Offices is that providing
Aid to this other location right or um
or maybe the the slip and fall by the
passer by is that related to the aid or
is that related to you know and so it's
going to be just a discussion es
essentially by the judge to make a
decision about where AID L that quote
Aid ends and where it doesn't and so
it's just going to create a whole bunch
of lawsuits thank you I will say thank
you I will say um lawyers are pretty
creative um I'll also say that it is
difficult to bring a civil claim um out
of all of the lawsuits filed in our
state courts in the past 5 years I will
follow up if I will follow up with the
actual data from the new Hamp from the
uh New Hampshire courts the
administrative office of the courts but
roughly 10% are civil um I'm 10% are
like you know civil claims that this
type of legislation envisions um we do
not have punitive damages in New
Hampshire we do not have runaway juries
lawyers that bring personal injury
lawsuits take these cases on contingency
fee they only get paid if and when they
win so we have many there is no there
are no frivolous there are no frivolous
lawsuits filed in New
stavis Oh I thought you had one okay
represent kahill you had one
sorry I'd like to go back and
representative Gilman go ahead thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question sorry thank you for taking my
question uh does it make any difference
to your position that uh this bill
provides that all public property may be
used as opposed to shall be
used
this can you point I'm sorry
representative can you point to the line
yeah it's number three it's the very
beginning of the bill all public
property May be used for leisure time
activities and temporary
shelter
um I mean sure but that I think that's
just
a May or shall is really I think that's
where the municipality would come in
it's their decision to designate it or
not so I understand that if this bill
were to pass this would not all of a
sudden exempt all governmental all mun
all property owned by governmental units
and
municipalities it would kind of kick in
if a municipality decided to designate
an
area now representative kill yes I was
just question on on the liability um say
say I I was Town X and I designated an
area let's call it San Francisco for for
a piece of land and and previously that
land was no overnight camping no
trespassing but now we've designated it
we've opened it up for for
use what happens when a tree falls in
the middle of the night on someone at
that location during a high wind storm
so New Hampshire already has um pretty
strong recreational immunity laws
um and forgive me for not knowing the
site on top of of the top of my head but
if you own a few acres of land and you
open your land for um
Recreation including built structures
and someone is injured on your land you
are not liable as is
today that's meant to encourage you know
hiking and snowshoeing Etc but if you
have a tree stand on your property and
someone you know goes with their kid for
a walk in the woods and the kid gets
injured on that tree
stand oh well you didn't have a duty of
care to maintain that
representative prct yes thank you Mr
chair
um we've acknowledged here I think that
uh homelessness is not just limited to
New Hampshire I'm wondering if you can
tell us about how other states or
municipalities are addressing this
liability issue with similar bills or
what are they doing thank you very much
representative um our
organization does have um sister
organizations in pretty much every state
so I'm happy to reach out to my
counterparts and see if this is coming
up in any other states um this has not
been something discussed by our National
Organization I'm not we have a list
serve I haven't seen this come across
um so I I don't know the answer but I'm
happy to do a little research I would
appreciate if you could get back to the
committee on that thank you very much
seeing no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony I have one
Grace thank you Mr chair Nate gra for
the municipal Association we do support
this legislation as you might imagine
the less money the trial lawyers make
off my members the happier I
am um realistically uh what we're
talking about here are activities that
are extra and voluntary in nature as
you've heard from the city of Rochester
um and and representatives from the city
of keen um these are activities that
their cities are engaging in that our
our members are engaging in um and what
this legislation would do quite simply
is remove uh the major
impediment uh to local government using
resources in a flexible and efficient
way to assist um when there is the
ability to help and that's really kind
of the the the the core of it um and as
representative Grassi presented
initially it's the fear of liability um
and the costs uh associated with
litigation that are having a chilling
effect on some of the conversations and
what to do uh to deal with some of these
issues that have Arisen I'm happy to
take any questions the committee may
have representative y Kella thank you
and I agree that this this bill should
uh a previous speaker said gone to
Judiciary and not this this committee
but um it seems like you in your
testimony you seem to disagree that this
that this um legislation might
actually
um dissuade
lawsuits and
um and the previous testimony said that
that the lawsuits probably will still
occur it's just whether or not they
might be successful or not so the the
legal costs essentially with defending
themselves would still occur maybe not
the damages but the cost of the the
lawsuit would still occur that you would
disagree with that statement yes because
I think the question is really how far
along with the lawsuit proceed so you
know anybody can file a lawsuit you pay
your couple hundred bucks you file a
lawsuit in Superior Court um and you go
to court and the attorney for the mun
IAL is going to file a motion to dismiss
because there's a immunity that applies
and the court may or may not have a
hearing on that and make a decision on
that immunity before you ever go to
trial so many of the costs with
litigation are um basically the Motions
leading up to trial and the actual trial
itself because there are depositions
there's you know hours and hours and
hours spent on all of this all this
stuff if the immunity kicks in
essentially you'll have the initial
filing you you'll have maybe a
preliminary hearing um a very kind of
short compact uh process which is still
going to cost some money but not nearly
as much money as a full trial and
assuming the immunity applies you will
no longer have a trial because the
immunity will exist you won't have a
trial you won't have damages you won't
have any of that so there would be a
cost savings on that
side for the questions see none thank
you very much thank you
no more pink cards on that bill so we go
ahead and close the hearing on uh
1544 and we will now go soon as I'll
here
good we open up the hearing on HB 1641
relating to requiring large parking lots
to have a solar power
believe we're getting there rep
behind I slightly behind today is this
power for the course or you usually this
far behind we've been doing well today
we didn't do so well we I'm assuming we
have representative MC Williams at the
thank you chair turkot members of the
committee it's a pleasure to be here and
present to you my name is representative
Rebecca McWilliams I represent South
conquered um you're actually in my
district so it's nice to host you um I'm
here today to testify um in support as
the prime sponsor of House Bill
1641 I'm calling this the uh parking lot
solar canopies bill um and I just want
to give you a little bit of background
in history because I think um while this
bill has landed in Municipal and County
it actually touches on quite a few
different issues that the house is
dealing with right now um so I'm if
you'll just give me a minute on
background I'll give you a little bit
more statistics and data on where we are
as a state right now uh when it comes to
land use and what's going on with uh the
state's
priorities um so I would I would say
that right now we are in a perfect storm
in New Hampshire with severe demand for
land um so what does that mean uh we've
got quite a few competing priorities
housing forest and agricultural use um
and Wildlife have historically been our
priorities uh New Hampshire has a little
over 600,000 housing units right now um
according to the 2023 Statewide housing
needs assessment we need another 60,000
units by 2030 and another 150,000 units
by 2040 uh so we need to find somewhere
to put a lot more
housing this is important this is about
what's going on with land if we could
please keep it to the bill the bill
talks about uh existing parking lots
existing parking lots solar array for
over certain size if we could stay to
that please absolutely um so then the
next question is what are solar canopies
solar canopies on parking lots um
provide substantial Energy savings they
lower the cost for maintaining the
parking lot they decrease the carbon
footprint they also use the space
effectively and allow for easy
integration of EV Chargers which we are
in the process of installing on our
major highways um solar canopies and
parking lots provide
um uh environmental justice benefit by
reducing Urban heat island effect um
they also enable energy Independence um
because there's more convenience for
drivers of electric cars and creating
shadier spaces um for parking so let's
talk about the uh Genesis of this bill
uh last year in July of 2023 the nation
of France uh passed a bill that was
enacted and they are now going through
with it um requiring solar canopies on
50% of parking lots with greater than 80
spaces um they're doing this because
they're expecting that the nation will
add several million electric cars and
heat pumps to their grid and they need
to diversify their energy sources and
storage
options um so how does that translate to
New Hampshire we're seeing changes in
our electric use in EVs and heat pumps
in the Northeast I expect New Hampshire
will probably follow our sister states
in the way that the market is changing
uh because they're abundant and they
cover large areas large parking lots are
obvious candidates for doubling as solar
arrays there are other benefits um this
Mass parking tends to be right next to a
energy hungry Urban uh development and
it's harder to make an argument that a
vast asphalt lot with solar canopies on
it would be any uglier than a vast
asphalt lot um you're also taking
advantage of basically free real estate
you already own the parking lot you
don't need to cut down trees or do any
additional um modification to the the
land you already
own um there's a financial benefit in
reduced cable length and preserving
rural Space by using these large parking
lots which tend to be in more urban
areas um for example according to a 2021
study installing solar panels over
Walmart parking lots across the United
States if we did all the Walmarts 300
3,751 Walmarts we could generate the
same amount of electricity as
approximately 12 coal fil fired power
plants so um there is an overall benefit
to using what we already have as
existing parking lots um parking lot
operators can charge EV owners to plug
in as well as using the electricity
themselves and the business the parking
lot is
serving the goal of solar P canopies on
parking lots in New Hampshire is to to
achieve multiple uses of Dead Space
without eating up land that we could be
using for housing Forest agriculture or
Wildlife make no mistake developers are
coming to New Hampshire to do solar and
the question is where are we going to
tell them to put it if we can tell them
to put it
somewhere um so without getting into
really heavy statistics um I would say
that um if we were to install solar
panels on approximately half of the
eligible parking lots so instead of
saying all of the parking lots over 80
spaces all have to have half coverage of
solar we take half again of that we
would be able to power approximately
31,900 New Hampshire homes each year
from the power produced from half of the
half of these large parking
lots um we're not the only ones looking
at this um in 2023 New York City made it
much easier based on zoning and setback
changes to install s canopies on
existing parking lots um and and that
allowed solar canopies to install to be
installed on approximately 8,500 Acres
of parking lots just in New York City um
if you'd like to talk about cost I can
get into the weeds and uh do a whole
business financial analysis um just in a
in a nutshell um I would say
that for a large parking lot owner this
is pennies and for a somewhat smaller
parking lot owner someone who's more
like the 80 spaces than say 200 plus
spaces um the cost is recouped in
approximately eight years so what I'm
talking about here is really a business
opportunity which pays itself off over
the 20-year lifetime of the solar canopy
in approximately eight years the
remaining cost to charge um EVS to the
public or electric savings for the
building user is approximately 12 years
of net benefit so with that I'm happy to
take any
questions representative your
H thank you thank you for taking the
question
um in in my municipality this year we're
putting in a a war warrant for changing
our
zoning which would classify different
types of arrays and allowing for
conditional use in certain options and
and um you know if it's a fix for a bill
it would be allowed and if it's not if
it's freestanding then it would be
contingent on you know conditional use
permits and stuff like that um it seems
like um how if if the bill passes um and
we have this um proposal or this this
RSA or this zoning uh
Amendment
uh mandating that all of our our parking
lots have this this
um these solar
arrays if we denied one that is
currently uh an existing parking lot
what would happen to that parking lot as
far as like you wouldn't be able to use
it as a parking lot or is it or you just
over riding the local control as far as
they have to Grant the the
uh the array or how would that work as
far as in relation to your bill thank
you very much for the question that's an
excellent question and it really gets
into the nuts and bolts of how this
actually works um looking to the way
that it works in the nation of France um
there are several exceptions for um
local control and for if an area is
absolutely not suitable for solar and
obviously in some of these urban areas
that are surrounded by tall buildings
it's a completely shaded site so you
couldn't possibly put solar there
because there is no solar resource um so
I would say um based on the France
exemptions for local control that would
be the intent um knowing that that's not
actually in the drafted text of the bill
as written uh but nonetheless I think
the intent would be that local control
can override if there is good reason I
wouldn't say every town can make their
own decision no matter what but with
denied representative we'll start down
to the end representative
priest thank you Mr chairman for taking
my question and and welcome again
um I gathered that this bill is a
retroactive so any existing parking lots
in municipalities that are surface that
meets this criteria would uh be required
to go solar that's correct um there are
two different deadlines there's there's
the 80 vehicles and then there's the 400
vehicles um so it is retroactive it's
for existing parking and of course it
would move forward so also new parking U
but the expectation is that if you're a
very large facility like a Walmart and
you have the 400 or more vehicle spaces
then you have a shorter deadline because
you're expected to both see the cost
benefit analysis and be able to come up
with the funding to do the project
whereas um the smaller Lots would need
more time representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so um when I
look at this it applies to existing or
new and I'd like you to comment
specifically on these parking lots which
would fall under this bill that would be
required to put up these solar cannabies
these parking lots that are associated
with Apartments like large housing
complex
so we could you please comment because
as I see it this type of a bill if it
were to become law would raise the
rental costs because the property owners
would pass that on to the renters and
that clearly would exacerbate our
housing um issue here in the state and
furthermore for example if somebody were
building more housing you know an
apartment complex and they were required
to put in the Solar canopy that would
increase the cost of building that
parking lot by a large factor and again
that would just go right into driving up
rental costs thank you very much for the
question and for pointing out the
concerns about residential development
both existing and uh future um I'm going
to give an example in my in my uh my own
constituency uh we have a couple of very
large apartment complexes that currently
have covered parking um due to the wise
decision not to have to do snow removal
for every single parking space but they
still plow the aisles um and so for a
situation like that there would be an
upfront cost obviously to install either
solar on those existing canopies or
install new canopies depending on the
age of construction um once again the
the real benefit to the facility and in
this case to the renters if you have
individually metered units the real
benefit is directing that energy that
we're producing back to the existing
building right but there's an additional
benefit which is being able to charge
for EV charging so you're going to get a
profit after eight years so the
additional 12 years is all in the black
for charging for EV charging depending
obviously on the initial outlay um so
just as an example to give you some
numbers to Crunch with this typically on
a business that has 80 parking spaces
you would do two EV Chargers um the
additional cost for this this is a level
three charger the fastest we've got it's
about an hour to full charge uh to do a
level three charger total initial outlay
is $50,000 so for two of them you're
putting in an additional $100,000 on top
of the cost to do the solar canopies
they pay themselves off plus the cost of
the colar solar canopies just through EV
charging in eight years obviously this
varies depending on how many people
actually own EVs and willing to pay for
that EV charging at the residential
complex that you're describing and once
again this is very market-based because
while we're seeing a shift to EVS it's
really hard to say when New Hampshire
will really get into the swing of things
whether that's in two years 10 years
hard to say hard to predict the
market I don't think that's the case uh
GM and Ford have already committed 100%
by 2030 um so moving forward big picture
I think what we're talking about is how
do you predict as a business owner who
owns a very large apartment complex
or as a condo board where everyone has
their own condo and they need to to
figure out how to do this initial outlay
are you going to take a loan and figure
out how you're going to pay it back or
are you going to come up with a way that
you're going to do a special assessment
on everyone it's a little bit different
when we're talking about a developer
who's doing a new condo complex because
when we're dealing with developers all
they care about is first cost as an
architect I deal with developers all the
time okay so that first cost generally
does get passed on to either a renter or
a condo purchaser because that's how
it's set up in our system and so we
could as a state put in an incentive to
incentivize developers to do this that's
not in the bill but it's a potential if
we wanted to make sure that this is
something we're pushing if we're not
pushing covering our asphal with
canopies and we're saying okay solar
developers put them wherever you want in
the state then we're taking a risk that
we just leave this um as as not our not
our direction for where we're going to
do solar wi is coming either way um so I
just want to be really clear when you're
doing doing new construction there are
ways that you can structure this with a
loan to pay it off over the long term
and it's whether it's a Buy and Hold
developer or whether it's just a spec
developer and they're going to sell it
with the initial first cost uh assessed
back to the buyer renter S
Davis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question which I think
should elicit a very brief
answer
um in line six the sentence that begins
Park Lots or facilities with X or more
vehicle spaces shall be in compliance
shouldn't that be municipalities shall
be in
compliance because doesn't the bill
require municipalities to to enforce
this so this bill is about everyone not
just municipalities um but you're saying
that the enforcement mechanism as the
municipality will start finding someone
who fails to achieve that what I'm I'm
saying is that this is the land use law
that you're
amending yes so it's not it's not
applying to private individuals or
developers it's applying to the land use
boards in the
municipalities and their
responsibilities thank you for the
question um to clarify the intention of
course is that someone like a Walmart
would fall under this bill not just the
municipal parking lot is that what
you're asking planning board to make
that requirement sorry Mr chair okay so
the planning board would enforce the
requirement because the Walmart has land
that's zoned by the municipality and
therefore they must comply with this um
I think that the language I think you
answered it let's move on representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for your testim me I thought you
were talking about another bill because
you're so enthusiastic about the the
solar energy don't you believe or would
you believe that I believe that that
this is an area that this is an area
where it's a matter of persuasion not a
matter of Law and uh do you also believe
as I believe that we should not be
putting excessive costs onto Private
indust Industry they should be willing
to do it and I think if they listen to
you they would be willing to do it but I
just so would you believe okay the
question has been representative Guthrie
representative Will Williams a yes or no
answer
please I would believe the second part
of your statement very good I've already
been cut off part is not we're not
aligned on that representative FR yes
thank you Mr chairman I have two
questions the first one will require a
yes or no answer the second one we'll
see
um the first question is does this
bill um contemplate
having essentially air rights to the
parking lot leased to a solar developer
or is the onus on the land owner to fund
and construct the solar
canopy I don't know how to answer that
with a yes or no it could be either
this bill does not anticipate one or the
other it could be either there's no
there's no restriction all right
followup uh
followup um parking lots or facilities
with 400 or more
spaces shall be in compliance by January
1 um are we referring here to Asphalt
parking lots only or parking lots in
general that are it says Asphalt in a
previous sentence but that sentence does
not mention asphalt as a limiting factor
or a controlling factor it's a it's a
it's a language um okay the question's
been asked let
the representative answer I believe the
intent is clear that it's asphalt um I
would certainly be glad to amend it and
add the word asphalt to the second
sentence to be super clear uh but the
intent of course is not dirt or gravel
or even porous pavers it's asphalt
representative K Hill thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I could
ask a hundred questions but I'll ask you
won't let's do one this
question do you
[Music]
see this say taking for example
affecting people like Len who's a pilot
say say we
force airports with massive parking lots
to put these in do you do you see this
as a hazard with glare for like Pilots
Landing like we're creating more hazards
with things like these
yeah um I think glare is an excellent
point and concern and France has
addressed glare as one of the issues
that could be a noo on this type of
project obviously it doesn't say that in
this language but that's the direction I
would follow quick followup one
followup do you think that you should
have included language like that in your
progress no comment representative
Gallagher
um so kind of a follow-up to
representative facts question um oh and
actually so first for disclosure I'm a
co-sponsor on this bill and we'll be
doing the asking questions rather than
testifying tact on it but anyways to
follow up on um rep fr's question about
other
materials um versus asphalt so um people
who have parking lots they they
theoretically have a bunch of different
options available with them like could
couldn't they um couldn't they say
repave their parking lot with a
different material or just deave it
entirely um to get around it instead of
building a uh solar
panel looking at the language of the
bill as written you could certainly go
in rip up your assalt leave it dirt put
in Porous pavers which would be even
better uh and get around this
repr
yella thank you uh for taking the
question um you've repeatedly talked
about
[Music]
like things that may be included or not
included in the language or in the
regulations that I it's unclear
about essentially um stavis recommend uh
referenced that um it would be enforced
by the municipality so the municipality
could create you know a warrant or a
zoning ordinance that
says considering all of the things that
you said should be added or may be
considered you know you know look to
France or
whatever or the bill should be fixed um
which is your preference I guess um
trying to fix the bill or trying to
leave it to the municipality to write
some zoning ordinance in compliance with
this um language I
guess I think it's probably a a split
the baby we would do half and half I
think that the actual enforcement piece
would be up to the municipalities
whether they're going to do a fine or
they're going to revoke a permit I think
that would be up to the municipality to
determine how to enforce but on the
first piece of your question in terms of
fixing the bill versus asking every
municipality to promulgate something
like this I would definitely say we want
to fix the bill this is the sort of
thing that is a market mover that
directs solar developers that if you're
going to do solar in New Hampshire you
should do it on our parking lots not our
fields and not our forests and certainly
not on land that could be housing and so
for that reason I think we want to do it
at the state level we don't want to have
municipalities deciding yes or no on
this quickly please yeah absolutely if
municipality was in not in agreements
with this could they just not enforce or
set a z penalty or whatever and just
essentially act as if this law doesn't
exist well certainly as written it
doesn't address any of that um so for
Amendment uh I think there probably
should be a mechanism to make sure that
it is enforced by all
municipalities representative Hicks
thank you Mr chairman thank you for um
taking the question and for pushing this
issue I'm putting my planning board hat
on a little bit and think think about
developers um and you know
representative Gallagher brought up ways
around this briefly I'm thinking about
um small parking lots connected by
travelways and if the travelways or the
connected parking
lots if they were under the size
required for this how would this bill
address that to further your goal of
so in you're hypothetical it's all still
one lot owned by one individual
yes yes but the parking areas are under
this yes to totally right all the
parking areas added up would would be
this but the travel areas how do you
define a parking lot sure this is based
on number of parking spaces which is
typically 9 by8 plus an i way um so you
know when you're calculating and you're
doing an outlay for a development which
I do in my day job um you're usually
allowing about 350 square fet per
parking space um that's the the number
that you would would allow for um that
solar representative
kill thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking yet another question so there's
been this move around the country in
developing to have permeable parking
Lots you know to deal with the water do
you see this as creating a huge swath of
non-permeable um area that that water is
now going to be changing how water's
flowing and creating a a problem with
water so you're talking about solar
canopies being worse than Asphalt in
terms of water well I I I'm saying
there's a move to use non to use
permeable um parking lot stuff there's
been lots of moves around the country to
find other means of parking lot material
an asphalt to deal with with water
retention and things like that but I I'm
looking at this example and it just
looks like this is just going to move
the direction of where all this water is
going so it's a great question um it's
something that comes up often when
developers are proposing solar arrays at
municipalities uh city of conquer went
through this about four years ago we had
a large array proposed um on Fort Eddie
Road actually pretty close to here um
and there was a big discussion about
okay when we do the solar canopies is
that going to redirect the water is it
going to change what we already see with
asphalt on on the surface we had all
kinds of scientific studies and
testimony related to that because there
was the concern that we needed to come
up with more Retention Ponds and some
kind of buffer to protect it um the
final answer was really there is no
significant change between having
asphalt flat and having a canopy that
directs the water in a certain direction
wash rep representative Gilman thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
for taking my question uh my question is
about construction if you have an
existing parking lot uh from what I've
seen of the solar rays that have been
installed in my
community uh they don't fit a car in the
space that uh supports each panel what
are has that been um looked into in as
far as uh
configuration or can can we do this or
well you answer thank you for the
question um yes this is the solar canopy
construction is in the norm now it's
it's common uh it's not particularly
common in New Hampshire but we're seeing
it nationwide especially in areas like
Arizona where there's plenty of solar
resource and plenty of asphalt parking
lots right it just makes sense um so
what you're looking at is this
significant structure that actually has
a foundation to it so you are digging up
your parking lot to put in concrete
foundation you're putting up supporting
structural columns supporting beams and
then you're laying several panels across
the entire width of it um with varies
depending on wind load snow load things
like that so say 15 to 20 feet maybe 30
feet depending on the site um for each
of these
welcome representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman so a couple
qualifying points first I have solar
panels on my home in New Hampshire and I
did it by choice but I also need to
point out that those solar panels have
snow on them right now and it'll
probably be on them for a couple of days
and I have to manually pull them off
even though it's on a sloped surface
which I assume these would be as well
because it's in New Hampshire
correct and then also I used to be a I'm
a civil engineer I used to be the
corporate manager for uh Fortune 100
company and did worldwide construction
we analyzed whether or not to put those
in our parking lots and chose not to do
them and they're still not doing them as
far as retrofits because it's not cost
effective for them so those are two
qualifiers but my point is this you
would be
requiring all private entities to put
these on your on their parking lots
correct with 80 or more spaces okay so
you'd be requiring followup
representative Brown so You' be
requiring to put them to a question so
be requiring them to put them on all
their Lots regardless of whether or not
there's a cost payback is that
correct so I just want to be
clear
the cost benefit analysis in the last
year has changed due to commercial EV
charging
stations
so I'm not an Financial analyst I'm an
architect but we are in an interesting
time where you can make back that
initial outlay through charging people
for EV charging within your large 80
plus parking lot if you're less than 80
this doesn't impact you it's 80 plus and
we now have the means to do that payback
if you are charging the public to do EV
charging as part of your development
final followup Mr chairman no
representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman for um and
thank you for accepting my question um
uh representative Brown kind of started
where I was going with with uh
parking and um upgrading them to solar
arrays uh if they meet the
criteria um do you have
examples of where this has been done in
the Northern New England states where we
get had a fair amount of snow some
Seasons um and what mean because what I
I've seen in the past for parking lots
are pretty much
level um and those are in the
Western Southern States and they do work
and they do pay back substantially in a
very short period of time but what about
the Northern New England states and do
you can you point to some examples
toward that sure happy to um so uh the
city of quinsey Massachusetts at the
walliston
and I believe it's the North North North
North quiny North Adams two of their T
stations out of four in quinsey um have
asphalt parking lots with solar arrays
on top um and and they used mpta funds
sense
represent
FR thank you Mr chair uh following up on
the issue of EV
charging um I would
hypothesize that in most residential
situations apartment
buildings um most people are
working 8 to five 9 to5 9 to6 whatever
uh when the sun shines and they're home
in the evening at night when they would
be wanting to charge their
EVS um have you figured people's working
habits into your payback
calculations and as
a follow on to that
question uh would you contemplate some
sort of a battery system so that
residences could charge their e v s
overnight I love this question this is
so like Cutting Edge technology is
awesome um I have I have a client that's
involved in this yes um first of all you
should know that GM is making a dual
Direction Charge car so you can actually
charge your car and then also charge
back in um to make some money in the off
hour representative we're going to stop
that has nothing to do with the bill
that's in front of us we've gone on for
an extended amount of time on this happy
to talk offline about this there you go
um see no other questions I have one
single question for you uh can owners of
the Condominiums apartment uh complexes
parking facilities can they do what your
man you want them to mandate to do uh in
order to capture the benefits that you
say are out there can they do that on on
the own now thank you for the question
Shar turot yes or no part of bringing
this bill forward is to educate them
that they can so thank you for the time
you thank you for Testimony as much as I
would love to drop the hammer we have a
couple of pink cards I'm going to ask
those speak into to please keep it brief
Nickerson
turn on that and also a a reminder just
to state for those of us here who don't
have pink cards in front of them whether
you have for or against the Bill thank
you okay I am against the bill my name
is Chuck Nickerson I'm the finance
director Fram County which is a member
of the New Hampshire Association of
counties um the reason I'm against the
bill is that as far as from the county
perspective it is an UNF unfounded sorry
unfunded mandate so for us for the 10
counties we all have nursing homes Co
county has two nursing homes so those
would be mostly your parking lots that
would meet the minimum 80 spots and
again we have no readily available funds
to front you know day1 cost for this
kind of
construction um so again that's primly
why we're against it as far as nire
Association counties Rock County in
particular um also I I believe that
solar Cy is like your most expensive way
of doing solar as far as your cheapest
would be again on like a a field or
ground mounted station the next would be
rooftop and then the uh the last most
expensive version is your solar can't be
and again um unlike others that can
Avail themselves you know private
individuals to tax credits that are out
there government entities generally
cannot you know take advantage of of
credits
representative PRI thank you Mr chairman
uh what if a solar investor came to you
and said we'll pay for this cost of
installing the canopy over your existing
parking lots and we'll give you some of
the profits from the electricity we
charge would you change your uh opinion
on this well again this case I'll
represent Rockham County and we have a
different project going on that would be
um when it's finally completed would
actually meet the 5 megawatt generation
already so in our instance Rockham
County specific we would not be in favor
of of that because we would
have already met the
limit representative
Gallagher um so kind of um to Echo my
question to your represent mck Williams
um so you mentioned it this not being
cost effective for um for putting up new
solar panels what if you instead took
one of the um
other uh Escape patches and either daved
the parking lots or repaved them with a
different material would that also not
be cost effective again that would be
additional costs the county taxpayers
which um as a f instructor I'd not be
proposing to uh my County Commissioners
or the
delegation
seeing no more questions thank you very
much for your testimony next I
Sherman thank you Mr chair members of
the committee uh my name is Philip
Sherman I'm the chair of the New
Hampshire building code review board I I
speak in gentle opposition to this bill
as it stands but I think think it can be
fixed
um two points very briefly one uh this
kind of thing we feel better belongs in
the codes than in statute let me give
you an example uh in a code we can
maneuver we can modify we can change
with a statute what is is what is what
if that Walmart showed up and said I
don't want to put 100,000 square feet of
solar panels on the parking lot I want
to put them on my roof a statue can
never never catch up with all those
kinds of contingencies where the code
process is designed to move quicker and
and deal with some of that uh the second
Point uh the the bill as it stands uses
the term parking facilities that would
include parking garages the building
code permits asphalt on the ground level
of a parking garage mostly because
that's the way they've always been built
so the School Street Garage I believe
the first level on grade is is asphalt
so there's some tweaking that needs to
be done there unless the intent is to
require these on uh the roofs of parking
garages as well um I'm also concerned as
one of the previous comments mentioned
uh as to what the enforcement and uh the
penalty type provisions and whether this
is just falls under zoning or whether
there are other Provisions that are
needed so I'll leave it at that happy to
answer any
questions
short and sweet thank you for your
testimony thank
Grace thank you Mr chair n Grace for the
municipal Association we do oppose the
bill um we oppose land use mandates this
is a land use mandate that would affect
uh Municipal uh lands
um I'm not going to repeat anything
anybody said I only want to add one
additional bit of information um based
on what I'd written in the fiscal note
where I provided LBA to write in the
fiscal note um I'm still unaware of any
other Municipal parking lots other than
the island path parking lot and Hampton
that qualify there may be ones that that
um that do um qualify um one thing the
committee may want to know is that the
island path parking lot was flooded as
of last week thanks to the storms and of
course some people have pointed out that
where the ocean comes once it'll come
again so I would simply point out that
it may not be a good idea to put more
infrastructure in the way of the ocean I
have no further comments I'm happy to
take any
questions questions seeing none thank
you for your testimony all right seeing
no more uh Pink cards we'll close the
hearing
1 okay uh we will go ahead now and open
up the hearing on HB
you have the
delay
well before uh sorry spillsbury hold on
one sec on the last uh blue sheet sign
and we've had a lot of blue sheets today
with nothing on them this one has three
con and two pro Mr chair along that line
um I believe the previous sponsor um
gave out some information that never
anything
okay representative spillsbury floor is
yours thank you Mr chairman and thank
you members of the committee this is my
maiden uh visit to this
committee uh nice to see a new audience
and get to see some put some faces and
names
together I'm here to introduce HB 1124
the purpose of which is to limit
conflicts of interest and excessive
concent ation of power for municipal
board and committee
members to a greater degree than is in
current
statute
um I have spent a considerable amount of
time in local Civic activity have served
on the Heritage Commission in
Charlestown for four years and shared it
two have been on the finance committee
for three years planning board for three
years shared that I imagine that this
committee is comprised of IND
individuals with similar range of
Municipal
experience in the course of my service
and particularly when I was on the
planning board I started to notice a
number of
uh situations where individuals were on
a multiple of different boards and
committees in ways that seemed like they
wouldn't be allowed or maybe they
shouldn't be
allowed and as I started to dig into
them I realized that the statutes we
currently have on the book that limit
the ability to be in multiple positions
are
scattered and uh
so I got onto the finance committee and
I read the statute on budget
committees and I see that it
circumscribes who can be a member and
there were a whole bunch of ways in
which our finance committee wasn't
conforming to that and I got my first
lesson about our finance committee which
is that Charlestown had not adopted the
statutory form of a budget a municipal
325 so therefore the view in the town
was that they there was absolutely
nothing that they needed to comply
with from the perspective of the
planning board um somebody came to me
and put a bug in my ear that we had
several members of the planning board
who were also on the conservation
committee so I dug into the statutes and
found that there's a provision
specifically saying that you can't have
a multiple of planning board members on
other land use boards that would
include a conservation committee a
Heritage commission or a
zba and then I realized that we had
three members of the planning board who
were also on the finance committee and
there's another provision that says no
more than two members of a planning
board uh can be on any other board well
these are
fragmented and I I started observing
other situations that I realized weren't
addressed at
all we have some statutes that tend to
say you can't have this couplet you
can't have that that
pair but we I don't find anything in our
statutes that limits the total number of
different um boards and commissions and
roles you can have so in Charlestown we
have uh I don't want really want to get
too specific about um names people and
positions but we have somebody who is
the elected uh town clerk in our town
that includes tax collector
that's another one of those things right
the statute says you can combine those
two
roles Town
Administrator member of the planning
board
um staffs the Water Commission and the
Sewer Commission and has only just
resigned um after she was questioned
from the finance committee these kinds
of things that I see in my community I I
I sense uh are found in in a variety of
iterations in many other communities
particularly small communities I
suppose and I recognize that the other
side of the coin is that there's always
a challenge to recruit um Civic
activists and bring in new talent and
but I I think that it's absolutely
essential to the good governance of our
communities that we diversify the voices
that are being heard and so so this
bill originated out of my asking myself
what do I think we should say about
elected
officials about full-time employees or
department
heads and about Civic
volunteers thinking about each of those
three groupings distinctly to see
whether they lead to the same conclusion
or different
conclusions and so you in my um LSR
request I
basically uh
asked to work to
draft uh for three
purposes no individual could serve
simultaneously on more than two
municipal boards or committees whether
elected or
appointed no full-time Municipal
Employee or department head may serve on
any Budget Finance planning or zoning
board or Committee of the same
municipality
nor any other board or committee that
has jurisdiction over any subject within
the scope of their employment
responsibilities and third no elected
official serving a municipality could be
appointed or serve on more than one
other volunteer position so elected plus
one volunteer times two full-time
employee um or department head in
certain specific limited
ways so in working with
OS I I also
asked given the
fragmentation um and it's because it's
fragmented you know uh there are areas
that don't come to people's attention
and in fact we even have a situation
where Municipal and
county has the jurisdiction over the
municipal rules but we have parallel
questions going on in our school school
districts some of which are entirely
within a community and dealt with in one
way and some of which are Regional
Schools and those those kinds of bills
and I have a couple of those are in the
education committee so it's not only
that we have fragmented laws we even
have a
fragmented review um and policymaking of
those
laws so OSS
suggested that in uh in terms of my goal
to bring things together as much as
6697 So
currently has a massive paragraph one
with seven sentences and they're kind of
hard to parse out you have to really get
your for me reading glasses on and look
closely to see where one sentence ends
and another one
starts so we decided that first useful
thing would be to just reformat at this
statute instead of a series of sentences
running on into a list so if you look at
hp120
1124 what you'll see is
that um paragraph one starts with a
direct statement of purpose which is new
language in order to eliminate conflicts
of interest and excessive concentration
of power in municipal government
colon
a through
F basically represent the individual
sentences in this big paragraph in the
current law I'll come back to them
because there are seven of those
sentences in the current law and there's
six in this bill and there are a few
edits but moving on
subparagraph so that's a through F
subparagraphs G H and I
represent the language to implement my
three purposes okay no board or
Committee Member serving on any
Municipal body Shall Serve
simultaneously on more than two
municipal boards or
committees no member serving on any
Municipal body shall simultaneously hold
elected or appointed office and be
appointed to or serve on more than one
other volunteer border Committee of the
municipality and finally an i no
full-time Municipal Employee or
department head Shall Serve on any
Budget Finance planning or zoning board
or Committee of the same municipality or
any other border committee that has
jurisdiction over any subject within the
scope of their employment
responsibilities so you've got three
groups
there volunteers elected officials and
full-time employees you've got four
Concepts that's what's new to this law
there is another provision that is new
but it's uh it's kind of incidental and
that's um paragraph four Roman numeral
four this is just simply saying that to
the extent there are conflicts between
this statute and those other fragmented
elements that this one is Paramount
Clause so if if I can then take you back
to
F A merges the first two sentences of
the current law because they are
virtually
redundant and it's the same list as is
in the first sentence except for two
things it brings in head of the town's
Police Department on fulltime Duty which
is currently in the second sentence of
the law and second it introduces Town
manager or other administrator which is
not currently in the
law so the purpose of this is just
simply to say each of these items in
veren in
B this more or less um tracks the third
sentence of the current law except it
broadens it instead of just limiting to
town clerk it says or Deputy town clerk
Town clerks serve very much they're
selected by you know live by the same
criteria and will sometimes step in and
fully perform the role of a town clerk
so any conflict involving a deputy
should be equally concerning to the town
clerk as it is with the town clerk the
other thing that it does is that the
current Statute in the third
sentence simply precludes a town clerk
from also being a town
Treasurer this this broadens it out to
say that a town an elected town clerk
can't be can't hold any other office
other than as um RSA
4145 um
allows the Town Clerk and the tax
collector can be
combined so I will admit that uh my
experiences are primarily based on
Charlestown um I am representative of
three towns and I'm aware of what goes
on in those towns too and there's very
similar concerns but not currently as
extensive and so I suspect that these
kinds of issues uh occur in many
communities at the same time I don't
have your um experience and wisdom in
Municipal and county law uh and I don't
presume to know how this plays out in
other communities so I just want to
offer up that uh I think this is a very
severe problem
I think it requires
legislation and if you think that there
are changes to my bill that would make
it um better or more or solve some
problem you see I would very much like
to remain engaged and uh help in the
preparation of any Amendment you might
think is uh is wise thank
you thank you representative uh
representative
savus I'm assuming you'll accept
questions please thank I'll be honored
by them thank you for um taking my
question I have two questions which I'll
praise as one and a followup if with the
chair's
permission um just generally overall uh
RSA 669 governs
elections many of the um positions that
you outline in your proposed Bill are
appointed positions they're not elected
positions so I question the um the law
that you're trying to Sure amend I think
that's an excellent question and I
raised the same question when OSS
pointed me to this statute as the one
that we should work with Okay but I
would point out while you're generally
correct that is not entirely correct
this deals with Selectmen who are
elected treasurers who I believe are
usually appointed moderators who are
elected Trustees of trust funds I'm not
sure if it's uniform they're elected in
my
community uh collector of taxes which
can be appointed or elected depending on
the um choice of the community auditor
which is certainly um appointed high
highway agent uh I think runs two both
ways in different towns it's uh so as
you go through here you will see that
this statute
already is dealing with both elective
and appointed
positions
follow um in
line 20 of your bill no member serving
on any Municipal body shall
simultaneously hold elected or appointed
office actually RSA 673
requires that on a planning board there
be a me an elected member of the select
board or the city
council serving on the planning board
sure so so this I think there two ways
of responding to your question um one is
that this says an elected official can
serve on another
board um second of all I think it's
entirely possible that you might fashion
an amendment that deals with the ex
officio
status representative power thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question I appreciate you um filing this
bill as well as giving your bill
introduction so um I understand that you
worked closely with the OS to draft this
so on page two lines five and six I have
a concern with with that part it reads
any conflicts between this section and
any other statute shall be resolved in
favor of this
section so I
like bills that we make recommendations
on to be to be very clear and I'm
concerned because in my analysis and
reading this
bill things get things are broken so it
breaks things and so one of the what I'm
concerned about and what I'm pointing
towards is that um RSA 673 col7 planning
board members serving on other local
boards well that would be an example of
something that this bill bill would
affect but it's not specifically
addressed within the bill this this
catchall sentence under section four of
the bill and I'm just wondering why you
know if something a bill before us is
going to
change other parts of Statute it's
better to deal with that
directly well I I agree wholeheartedly
with your last comment so if we confine
them all in concile them Bravo um this
was 's suggestion I defer to your
judgment on whether it's the right way
to go
um I would just say you know 6737 is one
I've paid particular attention to
because of my time uh on the planning
board and chairing it and I just want to
give you a sense of what's a
miss a planning board is comprised of
six elected members and an ex officio
from the select board
our current planning board is comprised
of the elected town
clerk tax
collector the
full-time director of the we head of the
highway
department the cemetery seant who a
full-time
employee the ex officio select board
that's already a majority and oh by the
way the other three include the chairman
of the school
board you sense a problem and what I
what I sense when I raise issues
locally is
[Music]
that there is an
overt effort to read our
statutes as literally and narrowly as
possible and look for any opportunity to
amendments representative Gilman thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I I'm I'm sort of on the lines
of uh of Representative Powers uh
question uh that there
are many sightings of of different uh
conflicts or not conflicts requesting
uh are saying that somebody uh from like
for example the HDC can serve on two
other boards so I understand your
restriction that they can only serve one
one but do you um given the problem that
a lot of towns have with
um finding volunteers to sit on their
boards would you say that this um helps
you fill the boards or or keep that that
volunteers I I think that the
hurdle of finding volunteers stands on
it own on its own and uh my mother who
was a 50y year plus Democratic committee
woman mayor of our village involved in
many different Civic
activities impressed upon me over and
over again that her number one job was
recruitment so in whatever activity she
was ever in she was always looking for
new blood um recruiting our communities
should be required to make that effort
they should not keep on looking inwardly
at the same half dozen to 10 people that
they're familiar with and appoint them
to this this and then that too so I
um it's there with or without this bill
and maybe this bill will even help to
sharpen the sense that somebody has to
take up the challenge thank you uh
followup Mr chair follow up um the other
uh concern that I have is that it's very
effective when um yeah your situation is
quite unique to me um in my experience
uh but the uh the question is
can't these
um different boards and commissions
benefit from the
crossover uh by giving the opinion of
how one affects the
other okay I think that's a very
subjective question that may play out
differently in different communities I
would just give you my personal judgment
is that it plays out negatively far more
than it plays out positively thank
you representative Holland so um so I'm
I'm trying to you know in in my
community the governing body the Town
Council really requires that a counselor
be on all of our committees we find it's
really effective to bringing the
information back to the council so we
work through it so so again since we
have a limited number of counselors and
a lot of um of positions to fill it's
kind of
challenging why are you legislating why
not allow the local municipality to
regulate itself and decide what they put
on I mean there's some obvious conflicts
of interest that you've placed in there
you're not allowed to do particularly
around fiscal and uh planning policy why
extend it to all voluntary why not allow
the municipality to somewhat decide on
its
own so first um I'm sure this plays out
differently in different
communities SE second it was not my
intention to limit the ex officio type
role that Selectmen play and we have the
same situation in our community where
several Selectmen are ex efficio to
seven or eight different boards that's
that's not what I'm trying to address
and if that's not clear and needs to be
made clear then I think an amendment can
be can clarify
that but as to why not leave it to the
local municipality to you know do
whatever they want
because experience is proving that it's
a very unfortunate situation with very
few people holding multiple roles and
uh the dynamic of how they make
lales thank you sir for uh bringing this
uh I noticed in your bill you do not
talk about relatives of uh
positions or uh extended family or I've
I've witnessed in our little town much
of what you have experienced but
also uh you know like a person uh on a
board having a direct impact on his
brother-in-law
and in New Hampshire I
think uh particularly in smaller towns I
think that is rather prevalent and it
has occurred for
centuries and it's I welcome this sort
of thing because I think it it's very
much needed but I'd like for you to talk
a little bit
about uh you you haven't really unless I
missed it well you it limits conflict of
interest but specific conflict of
relatives well I think you're bringing
up an
extremely important Point representative
lell it's beyond the scope of what I
attempted to deal with in drafting this
bill the inability or or what have you
to decide how that might be addressed
relatives
shouldn't hold you back from moving this
bill ahead I would just simply Echo your
comment that yes I too could give
examples in Charlestown and unity and
Newport um where that would be a concern
and and is currently you know we we
currently have husband wives on the same
board and that kind of thing but um I
imagine that if we tried to tackle that
issue in the course of this bill it
would bog it down but
good topic for the
future further questions representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair just one very
quick one in uh line number three where
uh which explains how to start uh in
order to eliminate conflicts of interest
and exce excessive concentration of
power in municipal government would you
be would you be willing to take out the
end excessive concentration of power and
I ask that only because a
negative uh doesn't often work in
passage of a
bill well I think ex I think that
diplomacy and compromises the order if
if you were willing to pass this bill
with that language absent I'd be
thrilled so no I I'm pass the Bill thank
you further
questions
thank you for your testimony I would
also Echo your your thought on putting
too much into the bill Beyond what's
here because the more you start loading
things down the more potential for
opposition here or there so I think I
thought I was going to bring you my
three proposals and with 's
encouragement we decided to clean up the
current statute so I hope we haven't
already gone a little too far thank you
representative okay I have one pink card
thank you Mr chair H Grace for the
municipal Association we uh we do oppose
the bill but in the interest of time if
it's of the in the chair's interest I'm
happy to work with representative
spillsbury to see if we can come to a
reasonable
compromise that was the best testimony
of the day and I would highly encourage
um representative spiber work with n uh
because I I think the
this subject of the bill
is really really good and I would hate
to see it uh not go anywhere so I would
encourage that highly any questions for
n thank you thank
you okay with that I do not see any more
pink cards I had uh one sign in on the
blue sheet and that was
against so that will close the hearing
on
um before I continue is there anybody
here to introduce 14 uh 1223 or 1478 at
the
moment I do not see them yet they may be
in hearing so what I'm going to do is go
at 3:15 we were scheduled to go to HB
1396 we do have somebody here to
introduce that so we're going to open up
representative
what's
that okay uh representative Alexander
1396 um thank you Mr chair for
accommodating me I have to go sling
beers in a little bit so I'm glad that
you're able to let me go so um for the
record my name is representative Joe
Alexander I represent the town of gtown
um I'm here on behalf of my friend
representative Barry who is unable to be
here today um I'm here not as a
co-sponsor I think I missed the deadline
on signing up but I certainly support
the bill um HB 1396 relative to
prohibiting Municipal inspections of
owner occupied units multi-unit housing
so uh representative Barry gave me a
couple things that he wanted to stress
so this committee heard this bill last
year um the committee voted um in
expedient to legislate outside a
committee but then the house floor has a
mind of its own and they decided to pass
the bill um as it is um so this is the
same exact version of that bill um so
the house has taken a position on this
um again just to reiterate this bill is
for houses um with four units or less um
it only apply only applies to the unit
occupi the unit occupied by the owner so
the other um areas of the
of the unit are subject to inspection um
this this to me is a property rights
issue if you own a house and you own one
of the units and you're living in the
unit no other single family unit or
house is inspected um if it doesn't do
any Commerce so this is this is really
just a way to keep government out of the
um out of your house and make sure that
um your privacy rights are being
protected so um with that thank you for
the opportunity and thank you for
indulging me Mr chair and are you open
to question questions yes very good
representative
priest uh Mr chairman this is uh not so
much a question to the the speaker but
to you but the the previous build that
we talked about in my rememory and I and
that my memory is going I got got to
admit is it was for duplexes and not for
fourplexes that may be that's not the
subject of this bill but that may be
okay thank you uh represent Gallagher
you had a question or well yeah but
actually um the representative priest's
question kind of covered it for me I was
um wondering how this bill managed to
get around the rule against
reintroducing a bill in the second um
year of a term but I guess if the
subject matter is slightly different no
the bill has passed the house we've
taken a position on the bill um the
Senate decided to the body on the side
of the wall decided to do something
different with it plus those decisions
are generally made by the speaker along
with the clerk
so it does look like it's slightly
different I think representative priest
four any other questions for
representative Alexander representative
uh you got you have representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so you had mentioned
in your testimony that this is a matter
of property rights which which I
support my question is is this
furthermore a matter of privacy rights
in
addition I I think that's a I hope
that's kind of that's a question right I
yes I would consider this a privacy
issue too um I own a townhouse in G town
and there are 11 units in the same row
and we own our own unit we own
everything the stud in our units are not
being inspected so I don't see this I
see this as being a privacy issue too I
think somebody owns a property they
should be able to um have the privacy in
their own home follow
up thank you Mr chairman and to be
totally I guess fair and impartial then
my question my follow-up question would
be do renters then therefore do they not
have priv privacy rights I I think they
should have privacy rights too but I
think the subject at hand is is the fact
that it's you're owned by the property I
think when you are a renter there's some
sort of liability that's encumbered by
the owner of the property so the owner
has an incentive to want to make sure
that their property is properly
inspected by the municipality to make
sure that the safety issues are being
addressed but I would say as an owner
owner occupied unit it's kind of like a
at your own risk like that's your own
property and I think that that should be
protected but I think by and large um if
if the landlord or or an owner they they
have an incentive to want to make sure
secure further questions representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
uh if there's a a
infestation say that it is generated or
begun in the property owner's unit would
the would the renters have a right
to sue or you know request a lower rent
or you know get rid of it and have the
owner pay whatever the process is for
removal of some bug or
rodent representative Alexander it's
perfectly okay to answer I'm not sure
I'm okay I'm okay saying I'm not sure
I'm not a lawyer in this situation thank
you at all forther questions represent
FR thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question uh are adus internal
to the structure included in your 4unit
count or
not well no um there's other legislation
dealing with adus and definition of adus
so I would say that um I don't think
that that is related to
this further questions representative
PRI
yes thank you for taking my question and
thank you for being here what if you
were a tenant of one of the four units
now and you found out that the landlord
that was occupying a unit was
doing structural things to his unit that
might be a fire hazard and might risk
the your life and the other lives of the
tenants how would you respond
I'm going to let somebody else address
that further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr
chair uh next we will'll call up I
mckenny
press the mic on there here we are good
afternoon uh chairman turkot and thank
you to the committee for allowing me to
speak before you today so my name is
Bill mckenny I'm the I'm the president
of the New Hampshire building officials
Association uh this bill has some uh
several concerns from our Association
members and code officials from around
the state the New Hampshire State
Building Code rsa1 15 5A addresses
permitting and inspections of all new
construction alterations and renovations
to include replacement of Building
Systems that could cause injury or death
if not properly
installed 155a does not get into the
maintenance inspections of buildings we
work in construction so I do believe the
focus of this bill is to the wrong
statute House Bill 1 uh 13 1996 proposes
to remove the authority granted from
Municipal agencies to confirm that
construction alterations Renovations or
replacement of Building Systems comply
with codes in owner occupied units
within multi-unit
buildings what prevents an owner from
renovating their occupied unit without
inspections then systematically moving
to other units to continue renovating
without further inspections endangering
other residents
owner occupied dwelling units should not
be Exempted from compliance with
building codes because of the risk to
other residents in the same
building a similar bill in
2023 was due to a code enforcement
housing concern in one New Hampshire
community and it incorrectly targeted
Code if this is still the concern with
house bill
1396 then I believe what they should be
looking at is housing and maintenance
standards the maintenance code and the
housing standards that are adopted by
the state are not part of RSA
155a if the issue is due to local code
enforcement and housing regulations then
it should be addressed at a local level
not as a Statewide leg legislation that
endangers residents of all multi-unit bu
buildings RSA 155a the New Hampshire
State Building Code is intended to
protect all those who live work and play
in New Hampshire and if amended pursuant
to RSA
1396 then lives are put at risk and with
that I will entertain any
questions thank you for a testimony
anybody uh seeing none I do have one
quick one for you you said that you
don't believe 155a is the proper RSA for
this what would did you mention what RSA
you believe we should be focusing on
I I believe in the state of New
Hampshire communities M municipalities
have the authority to Grant housing
standards under the health codes health
regulations they also have the ability
to adopt the uh property maintenance
code um but those are not adopted by the
the property maintenance code is not
adopted by the state of New Hampshire
and it's not part of RSA
155a okay thank you further questions
seeing none uh thank you for your
testimony thank you
robers good afternoon members of the
committee for the record my name is
Michelle robers and I'm the bureau chief
for public health protection within the
division of Public Health Services at
the Department of Health and Human
Services and with me today is uh Sophia
Johnson and and she's the Department's
Health officer liaison um this bill
recently came to our attention and while
the department doesn't have a formal
position on the bill we do have some
concerns about any unintended
consequences this bill may have limiting
Health officer authorities for
inspection under RSA 147 and with that
I'm going to turn it over to my
colleague Sophia to kind of give you a
little bit more information relative to
that
thank you chair and committee um so
similar to um representative Gilman's
question about infestation currently um
RSA 147 allows local Health officers to
conduct sanitary investigations um where
there are public health concerns so in
this situation if an owner occupied unit
in a multi-unit building had let's say a
bed bug infestation if that owner failed
to appropriately address that
infestation those bed bugs could could
then move to the adjacent units
affecting other tenants um similar if
the owner was not able to effectively
remove trash for some reason now that
odor is going to begin to emanate an
impact um again surrounding tenants so
with this legislation we're concerned
that now the local Health officers would
not have the authority under 147 to
conduct those sanitary investigations
that could have public health
implications for the surrounding unit
thank
you certainly happy to answer any
questions thank you representative
priest thank you for uh taking my
question and thank you for being here
would this also included in the black
mold if the first unit has been flooded
and they were not mitigate it would that
also be a health hazard to the adjacent
units um certainly depending on HVAC
system systems um and the ability of
those mold spores to transfer to other
units it it could impact other units
yes representative yella thank you um
thank you for taking the
question if
the uh building in question is not
um uh multi-unit housing do you still
have do you have that same power um and
then where is that line as far as like
if it's a formal two multi-unit building
or just someone you know renting out a
room in their back of their house with
no you know notification to the town
does that um allow you some some uh
Powers what where does that line yeah
it's a great question and I'm I'll will
preface that I'm I'm not an attorney but
what the department has um how they have
interpreted that statute is RSA 147
applies to situations that have a public
health impact so if there's a private
residential home health officers would
not have the authority to go in and do
an inspection if there's concerns for a
sanitary issue that is a that is their
private home it's not impacting again
surrounding um units or surrounding
homes and they don't have that Authority
but especially in situations where homes
are directly adjacent if they're sharing
a wall um if there's the ability of
let's say rodents to transfer between
units then they do have that authority
to go in does that answer your
question do you have followup I'm happy
to follow up
um yes I in some sense um if you're
taking a very very narrow view of of
public impact then that could be but
let's say a homeowner that is not
renting has bed bugs they can transfer
that to you know the the local uh Hotel
if they bring their luggage that has
bugs in it to the local hotel so if
you're if you take that view and saying
hey if you had bug bugs and you're a
private residence then we could see that
as a public health emergency if or a
situation because you could leave with
those bed bugs and take them elsewhere
and spread that so how it seems like
you're not defining it that way but you
could um and so um there's some vague
vague language it seems like from my
perspective I don't know if you see yeah
it's certainly a great question and I
think I'm going to take that back to our
team to delve into a little bit more but
I appreciate that
comment further questions I just have
one oh did you have one rep gagher did I
see your hand go up no oh no I didn't
all right uh I have one you mentioned uh
RSA
147 is what you operate under correct
that is correct I'm over here over here
so yeah
[Laughter]
hi um this
bill 147 is Health inspections sanitary
investigations this bill is specifically
on Building Code Enforcement Authority
why is it you believe that this bill
would somehow affect your department
with 147 RSA
147 so the concern is around the
definition in RSA 155 of local
enforcement agency which includes um
municipality that's adopted enforcement
Provisions or additional regulations
under um and they cite two two things
but they include building inspector code
official or local government official
and so there was some concern about any
unintended
consequences that uh the health officer
would be considered a local enforcement
under this definition of local
enforcement
agency am I misreading this it says the
local enforcement agency appointed to
enforce the State Building Code doesn't
say anything
other I think it's this part
okay I think it's the latter part that
says other local officials qualified and
authorized to make inspections and to
enforce the laws ordinances and rules
enacted by the state and by local
government that establish standards and
require requirements applicable to
construction alteration or repair of
buildings where are you reading that
from um it's the line it's the
definition in RSA 155
okay thank you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
tou this
morning we have one more pink card on
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh Philip Sherman chair of the
New Hampshire building code review board
uh this bill proposes to prohibit
building inspection building inspectors
from inspecting owner occupied units and
multif family residential structures up
to four units I believe this may in fact
be more appropriately focused on routine
housing health or Property Maintenance
inspections the foundation that the
building code is based based on involves
a permit structure including Pro
reviewing project documents issuing a
permit inspecting the work and usually
issuing a certificate of occupancy or a
similar document in the situation where
an owner is doing work that is or should
be covered by a building permit
inspection of the work is an integral
part of the code system especially in
multif family structures work done in an
owner occupied unit May well affect
other units in the building for instance
as mentioned previously improperly
cutting into a structural member I
respectfully suggest that work that is
or should be covered by a building
permit be Exempted from this inspection
restriction but further there are cases
where the building inspector may need to
enter a unit subsequent to structural
damage a fire flood or other damage to
determine whether the building or unit
may be safely occupied
again this damage might impact other
units in the building in summary I feel
that this issue is best addressed
somehow to housing Health Andor Property
Maintenance codes but if it needs to be
addressed to the building official work
requiring a permit and emergency
conditions should reasonably be Exempted
uh perhaps uh the the words for cause or
without cause needs to get in here so
that there's a reason to enter a unit
and again I'm happy to take any
questions but also to work with anyone
who requests assistance on the wording
Provisions thank you for Testimony
questions seeing none don't leave um one
question
um in uh 8 n1a of the bill it's it
basically says that the local
enforcement agency appointed to enforce
shall not have the authority to inspect
owner occupied
units would it improve the bill or
change your mind if there was an
additional few words on there something
to the effect unless the authority is
given by the occupant you see where I'm
getting at the way it's written it says
shall
not but my point is I think there are a
lot of owner occupied the owner the
owner occupied unit the owners of that
unit might not necessarily have
opposition to somebody coming in a
billing inspector and helping and I
would say maybe even the majority so
better I guess I'm not sure I understand
your your point point would be uh on say
on line 10 after where it says
Building
Code Enforcement Agency shall not have
the authority to inspect owner occupied
units in residential multi-unit
structures of four units or less unless
occupant well on on first reflection of
course that's the problem right if if
the owner is going to let somebody in
then it's go ahead and inspect but if
the owner resists and there's either
work that's going on that is or should
be covered by a permit the official
needs the legal authority to inspect
that work U and furthermore my case of
the emergencies and so forth uh many of
which were related to the the issues the
health folks brought up so I so the
answer would be no I believe if I
understand the question correctly the
answer is no okay further questions
anybody seeing n thank you for your
testimony thank you oh uh we will go
ahead and close the hearing on HP 1396
on the blue sheet have one uh individual
against okay we have two more bills and
I see neither of
the sponsors or co-sponsors here so what
we will do as we do typically in this
committee is we will have somebody
introduce and if there's anybody who
wishes to speak for or against you will
be welcome to do that I will let you
know in advance that in general this
committee if the sponsors aren't here
that we generally do not recommend
passage so um with that we will go ahead
and open up hearing on HB
12233 relative to governing body members
of the B budget
committee um representative Brown while
you're up could you introduce the bill
for
us you'll have to do it up front though
you
thank you Mr chairman uh the committee
all knows me Richard Brown
representative from molb bro torth and
Madison uh this bill uh House Bill
1223 uh for municipal and County
government this bill clarifies the role
of the governing body members for
committees thank you for the introdu
uction are there
any I don't think
the what I'd like to question to witness
at
late I'd be glad to do that
representative
majar I think that um I would have been
happy to to introduce since I've
actually proposed this legislation in
the past and uh so I would advocate for
it not be automatically killed right so
I would be happy to
would been happy I do not see your name
on no no I haven't I haven't I didn't
sponsor this one but I've P I've
proposed such legislation before and so
I already um predisposed to support it
so the um you can make your statements
known in the executive session I don't
think representative Brown is prepared
to take question and answers on this on
this Bill thank you for the introduction
uh I did did have one individual who
heck good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Katherine Heck from The New
Hampshire Municipal Association and I
will be very brief as written we oppose
House Bill 1223 I had spoken with the
sponsor about a possible Amendment um
and he had considered but again I can't
speak for him perhaps a a local option
we know that we have about
93 budget committees we know many of
them um I did do a survey and got
responses from 60 of them are
functioning um very well they like
things as written so we were hopeful
that there would be um an opportunity to
work together to craft um an amendment
but without the sponsor here I can only
written okay
would you willing to take some questions
it's totally up to your time and
representative
M thank you for taking my questions as
you know uh on the W budget committee we
had nine voting members and with your
guidance uh we went up to 10 so now we
end up having ties of five to
five uh with one of those people that's
now voting now is one of the Selectmen
and I was just wondering what we can do
to this bill that would get your support
so we don't have that
situation as I mentioned that we again
had spoken with the sponsor about
crafting out um a local option that
would be a new Option and certainly
would leave any budget committee that
wishes to remain exactly the same intact
so we would be happy to to work with
anybody on that thank you representative
yella thank you so you're hinting at
your your um the policy of the nhma to
support any uh flexibility as far as min
municipalities having the option to do
what they they want um um and so you if
if the bill was changed in such a way
that the local voters would be able to
um let's say put in a warrant article or
or the or the governing body put in a
warrant article to um to change their
membership to something uh approxim and
mainting this language that you would be
in favor of that change I I think we
would be we would neutral on the change
okay but as long as it's clear and
enactable and doesn't leave room for
misinterpretation then we would we we do
like to support or remain neutral on
local
options thank you for your testimony
representa Davis um I think this is a
question for you Mr chair just
procedurally if the sponsor is not
present to respond to questions is it
appropriate for other committee members
to suggest amendments to a bill if the
sponsor is not here I think it's that's
can be done I'm not sure that's going to
sure further questions seeing none thank
you for your testimony close the hearing
on HB
1223 representative Brown here to
thank you Mr chairman for letting me
introduce House Bill 1478 on behalf of
Representative Roy um this bill
prohibits a person from serving on the
local select board or other Municipal
governing body and the school board in
the same
jurisdiction thank you
representative are there any I don't
have pin cards I don't have anything on
this bill permission to treat the
witness as
hostile yeah I like it um I will I'm
ready I will note
that uh the bill that we heard from
representa of spillsbury
I'm wondering if maybe these two bills
are possibly already incorporated into
his
extremely uh large number of changes
there that might be the case I know
representative uh represent I know n n
is going to be working with
representative bilsbury so maybe he you
don't have to come up I'm
just very good thank you seeing no more
and well we end up close
but all right uh thank you everybody for
a long day um next week we are meeting
on Wednesday again in the morning we are
going to uh exact some
bills and in the after afternoon we are
going to have a few
more hearings on four five bills so
week